Now we're live on new stream.
It's a series of events
that have to take place.
Tommy buns.
I like it,
including me shutting off my laptop.
Oh really?
No.
My,
my uh,
my volume.
I'm,
I'm a retard.
I always leave it on and it always,
I always,
there's like a checklist of shit that I
should do for the podcast starts number
one.
It turned the volume off of my
laptop so I don't hear myself.
So that's stupid.
Right?
I'm sure we should.
We should put together a list,
put together a list checklist.
I need to get my shit together.
Me,
it doesn't look like
it's getting any better.
The Joe Rogan experience podcast
is brought to you by on it.
If you go to o,
n n I t he will check out some manly
shit like kettle bells and battle ropes.
That's the kind of Shit I be using lately.
I hired a trainer recently.
Did you really?
Yeah.
This young dude that I do Jujitsu with,
it's always an awesome
shape and kicks my ass
ass.
These fucking workouts are so brutal.
Cross training style stuff.
Well,
I feel like if you don't
have someone yelling at you,
you know,
getting you to do shit,
it's like no matter how
hard you push yourself,
you don't quite push yourself
as if not even close man.
Someone else does it.
Yeah,
that's exactly what I don't push myself.
that's exactly right.
I just started doing that recently.
It's pretty bad ass.
I do it for,
I hire somebody once every once in a
while for like a month and I'm like,
that's just too hard.
I got Justin,
he trains in my gym and he would,
we would,
I would watch him,
his train and I'm like,
this guy never gets fucking tired.
So I said like,
what are you doing for conditioning?
He told me he's a trainer and so I said,
let me one more time.
Which one day he had me doing all kinds.
How long the workouts are you doing?
Shit,
it's only an hour.
That's all I can tell you.
But intense hour is tarted,
dude.
It's all like Madison balls and jumping
over this and jumping squats and all
this nutty tracking on the field shit and
jumping over boxes and pushups left to
right,
left to right,
left,
right,
like all this crazy like
conditioning type shit.
Holy Fuck.
Is it hard to do whenever every time I've
done a workout with a trainer and it's
been like an hour,
I'm always amazed at how little
I usually accomplish in an hour.
You know what I mean?
Cause like you finished with
the trainer and you're like,
man,
we did all,
we did that in an hour.
I usually spend an hour and I do
a fraction of one of those things.
It's hard to
really fucking bucks down,
feel it a little bit.
I could do it every now and again,
but I think on a regular basis sometimes
you need to take a class or you got to
have somebody yell at you.
It's like working with a deadline.
Like you were working on a deadline
and you analyze what you accomplish and
then,
and then when you're on your own again,
you're like,
yeah,
you feel like it.
Lazy Bitch.
What's wrong with me?
I am always,
I've worked with a deadline a few
times from the road and I'm like,
Holy Shit,
how much work I just
accomplished this weekend?
And then it's usually the,
the opposite thought.
Like,
Holy Shit,
I went the entire weekend
without doing one product.
I got up and I went down to do the
show and I dropped off four times.
That's the day.
It's amazing how much time you can waste.
It's an amazing,
but it's a crazy feeling when you set
the bar really high and you accomplish
something and like you
short period of time,
you accomplish a lot of
things because then you know,
you've got to keep that pace up.
Oh,
that's brutal.
Yeah,
it's hard.
It's very hard.
That creative pace,
this has nothing to do
with on a.com or cattle.
That was a fun time.
But whatever,
folks,
go buy some vitamins for your brain.
Some mushroom tech sport.
We have hemp protein powder.
We have kettle bells,
as I said,
battle ropes,
all kinds of cool shit.
All of it.
Health and fitness related and uh,
and mental focus and clarity related.
You're still the sleep one?
Yeah.
Well it's not asleep.
One,
one that's a,
it's a mood booster.
It's a five HTP and l fan.
A supplement does have melatonin.
No,
I don't think so.
It does it,
I should know that.
Let's Google it.
Um,
because it's what don't do it.
Don't you think what it does?
Um,
did you get bill blade?
What it does is it's five HTP,
um,
produces a,
it makes your brain produce serotonin
and l tryptofan converts to five HTP.
So it like literally it's like a,
it acts as sort of a time released
formula for helping your body produce
essentially what makes you happy.
But people have heard,
cause I haven't tried it,
but I've heard other people talk
about since they started it,
they sleep better.
They said,
they told me that,
well,
there's a lot of things that
can make you sleep better.
Um,
zinc and zinc is a good one.
That zinc,
magnesium stuff.
That stuff was good.
That's the,
it really,
um,
helps you,
uh,
really,
get a good deep sleep.
But a lot of people have
good success with Melatonin.
Melatonin has a,
yeah,
I've tried Valerian root,
but that would get that Gamey
psychadelic dream crazy dreams.
Have you ever tried it?
And I'm going to now have to try it.
That seems amazing.
I've had bananas fucking dreams on that.
Oh Wow.
It's like nature sleeping.
The craziest Shit I've ever
done is the Alpha brain dreams.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Alpha brain especially.
It seems like the,
uh,
the old formula may be fucked
with your head even more.
The real formula,
either that or I'm used to it,
I'm not sure.
Um,
but what it used to do to me was
giving me these crazy lucid dreams.
There were really strange because there
were so much more like potent than my
normal dreams.
Like I,
they were like,
this is how I describe it.
It's like my normal dreams or
like a bubble that a kid would
below and they're blowing
those soap bubbles.
It's like so fragile.
It's so fragile.
These dreams were like basketballs.
Like they were hard,
right?
Like they were real.
It was,
it was really strange because it was
like I was aware that I was dreaming,
but I was still able to
maintain the dream state.
I've never been able to do that before.
Maybe.
Maybe we've been able to do
that for like reef seconds.
I've never tried.
Apparently there's this thing called,
um,
a lucid dreaming where you can actually
practice certain techniques that can aid
you and into literally
manipulating your dreams.
That's awesome.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I've never tried it.
I'm too scared that I would like that too
much and I'm fucking forget real life.
I'm fucking bad ass and my dreams a dream.
Oh,
it'd be worried.
I would be worried that I wasn't
dedicated enough time to real life.
It's,
that's like virtual living,
right?
Like,
I mean,
there are times when you
wake up from a dream,
you're like,
the dream was so awesome.
What?
She kind of go back to sleep and I don't
know if anybody's that much of a master
that they can really control it that,
but there's somebody like that.
If I focus on what I
want to dream about next.
I just did it yesterday.
I don't know why,
but I wanted to dream
about Phyllis Diller.
I was like obsessed with her yesterday
on my dream about Phyllis Diller and I
went to sleep and I did Phyllis Diller.
Wow.
Why were you obsessed with Phyllis Diller?
I think because,
uh,
Tommy's cousin came over and,
and Phyllis Diller sent me
like a note that I had framed.
Like she encouraged me
before she died in my career.
So I just have this bond with her.
I love her.
I'm fascinating with
her life and everything.
Wow.
And I just wanted to,
I don't know,
want to talk to her or something,
I feel as how did you feel better?
I dreamt about her house.
Yes.
I dreamt that I slept in her bed and
then it's split in two and I fell on the
floor.
We've got to give you some Alpha
brain fucks with your head.
Yeah.
Too late or do you take
the Alpha brand new?
You'll come back with like I just did a
Europe tour with Phyllis Diller and like
stories about the road.
Anyway,
we've got to get to
these stupid commercials,
right?
Joy,
joy,
scared.
I'm having a heart attack.
Anyway,
go to Onnit dot.
You use the code name Brogan and you
will save yourself 10% off any n all
supplements aren't you?
Freak Freak bitches.
That sound good.
I like,
ah.
We are also brought to you by
[inaudible] our newest sponsor,
a kerosene games.
Kerrison Games makes us bad.
Asking called Blade slinger for the IPAD
and the iPhone and it's a a really good
game that was made from the ground up
for a pad instead of like a computer game
that they poured over.
This is a,
an actual high end game,
a really beautiful graphic fun game that
was created just for the IPAD and the,
the graphics are insane.
It's really cool.
Really cool looking like a real,
I mean it's,
what they can do now
is so amazing with me.
Even just an IPAD,
the computer processing power and the
visual processing power allows him to do
some really cool shit.
And the Games only two 99.
So if you're not having an iPad,
it's called Blade slinger.
Go and check it out.
You dirty freaks.
All right.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible].
This is the last one.
I swear.
If you go to a rogan.ting.com
isn't that what it is?
It's [inaudible] dot com backslash
Rogan go flat slight for calm.
Don't confuse people.
You fuck you work here.
Um,
that's not it.
I'll find it.
I'll find that URL while I do this.
But what's important is what ting is.
And Ting is a cell phone
company that uses sprints,
backbone and um,
they,
but they,
what they do is they make it really
fair and they don't have any contracts.
You can quit whenever you want.
It's the same service
that you get with sprint,
but it's like they,
they don't have you as locked in to this.
Just sort of a shitty situation that
you can get in with a regular cell phone
company,
regular cell phone company.
When you buy a phone,
like say if you buy a phone
and it costs like 500 bucks,
what it really costs us
probably more than that.
It probably really costs like 700 bucks.
But they,
they take it and they apply it to your
contract so that if you are going to
stick with them for three years and
give them x amount of dollars a month,
then it's worth it for them
to sorta take that money,
take a little piece of that
and pay off that phone.
Well,
when you want to leave early,
that's why you have to pay these
cancellations places like several hundred
dollars,
you know,
that doesn't happen with Ting.
You can get the exact same
services you get with sprint.
So it's like really good
cell phone service is shit.
Joey Diaz swears by and it's um,
you,
I'll also get,
it's the best cock sucker when I got to
tell you what the fuck do I got to tell
you?
I'm telling you is not to be fucked
with sprint is not to be fucked with Joe
Rogan ducks St Com.
That's what it is.
Um,
if you go there,
you will save
it's rogan.ting.com.
You A,
if you go there,
you will save 50 bucks off of,
uh,
any of their android devices.
I have the Samsung Galaxy s three,
and it's the shit.
It's fucking awesome.
It's a beautiful phone.
Like it's,
it used to be that it was
by phones or you know,
crap.
And uh,
that's just not the case anymore.
These,
these really beautiful big android phones.
They get my dick hard.
Oops,
I said it,
I said it.
I don't think this is,
the client's not happy about this.
It's not a part of the,
we were listening to your library
once you get online with it,
one of those men that you'll,
it's so hard to go back to even an iPhone
when you get online and you look at
websites,
it's like,
it's almost like having
a tablet fucking huge.
It's like 4.8 inches.
And they have a galaxy and well I
don't know if these guys carry it,
but there's a new one that Samsung
has cause they called the galaxy note.
That is just preposterous.
It is.
It's an iPad mini got,
damn it.
It's huge.
I get such screen envy when I
see it and I got that from the,
the galaxy s three,
having that thing.
It's changed the way I look at,
uh,
I used to think there were too big,
I don't think.
Yeah,
that's pretty good.
Cool.
All these phones have
seven o'clock on him.
I just realized,
dude,
it's a lucky number.
Superstitious.
The other one of were scared.
You see somebody a at a show,
take pictures when they take
pictures with that Samsung,
you were looking at you,
you're like,
whoa.
It's like someone brought
up the photo on a computer.
Like it's so much clearer.
Right.
Huge.
Huge God damn screen.
Anyway,
go to rogan.ting.com and you
will say 50 bucks off of,
uh,
any of those android
devices or any dirty fucks.
Thank you all for listening in.
Brian,
play the music.
Let's get a roll man.
Joe Rogan experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
That was one of our longest
yet most enjoyable commercials.
Fantastic.
Cause it wasn't,
I mean it wasn't,
it wasn't,
you know what I'm saying?
Man,
I know you sent me brother
to me a little bit of both.
I was going on there,
Tom Segura and Christina pee.
I got to give you guys world champion.
Funniest couple.
Yeah,
thanks Mandi.
Uh,
the,
the breaking of the mold
of every entertainer with
an entertainer is in a shit
relationship.
Sure.
You guys can totally fix that.
Yeah,
thanks.
It's always like,
it's always like the dude's funny and
the check is like good looking and he
writes jokes for her.
It's like,
what a Lowe's or,
or it's,
you know,
that the,
the,
the guy's funny and he takes
the girl with them on the road.
It's very rare that there's equals.
Yeah.
You know,
but you guys are both really funny
and you really love each other.
You get along and it's
like a weird and hot
both artists.
Fuck.
But it's very,
it's a,
that's a weird situation
that it actually works.
So lucky.
Yeah.
We did ask about it all the time
when you guys would suck.
It's usually one of your sucks.
Right?
Am I right?
For sure.
Oh definitely.
Originally like you have
to hang out with this guys.
No,
really annoying.
A wife who's also a comedian or really
annoying husband who's also a comedian.
Oh yeah.
And she's actually has
less tolerance for it then.
Not like when we go
out with other couples,
she's always like,
don't leave me at the table.
Some boring fucking yeah,
I hate while you go have fun.
Okay guys.
Comics like it's usually
dudes and then they have like,
you know,
wives,
it maybe not ours.
Inspiring.
And I always want to hail to dudes and
talk shit about how many and then I
always get stuck swab and fucking
apple brown Betty.
I'm like,
I talk about Slos man.
Like,
like
let's talk about some shit.
They have to find you by your vagina.
You got lumped it to the wrong group.
Oh Shit.
Thank you.
Speaking of which did you hear about
this fucking 50 year old guy who um,
he had a sex change [inaudible] and
now he's playing college basketball.
What?
That college has to wore men's basketball.
He's enormous.
Weight it out.
Did he?
This is,
I don't know about this is hold on.
This is really,
you just made me really think about this.
Did he have college eligibility or did
he already go to college as a man and
then since he's switched sex,
she has new
cause that would be so
awesome if he did that way.
Dude,
this thing,
this guy,
okay,
I'm probably very sweet,
sweet person.
I shouldn't say thing,
but this dude slash woman woman,
now I'll say,
what did I say woman?
A woman that used to be a man,
let's call her a woman.
She is six foot six.
Whoa.
She's not like a giant man and
she's decided that she's girl now.
So she has the sex change operation,
but she's still a six
foot six man bodied woman.
Big Badge.
That is like if you're looking at all
these little girls that are playing with
her,
he man,
if your daughter was playing basketball
with a dude that was pretending to be a
woman or because decided
to become a woman,
you can't.
That's all fine and
good for the real world.
If you want to define yourself as a woman.
But we will enter into athletics.
There's a reason why there is fucking
different categories for men and women
get an unfair advantage.
Oh my God,
man,
that's crazy.
The other thing is
two is because the one thing that's hard,
I think when you're,
you're not involved in this,
but you see somebody,
let's say who gets a sex change
and I'm saying outside of Sports,
right?
Just in life you go there like,
Hey,
you know I've decided to do this.
I'm a woman now,
and you go,
okay,
all right,
you want to be like,
fine,
you're a woman now.
But there's that part in
my mind that always goes,
yeah,
but when I look at your hands,
even if you've had surgery and everything,
those are still man men's hands.
You know what I'm saying?
Those are men's arms
that you have and legs.
Even if you have like implants in
and you change your whole face,
like that's still a
guys bicep and your arm,
even though you had a sex change,
so you're still,
so if you think that's a sports,
yeah,
that's where it all counts.
That's where your original
allergies the other way as well,
because there was a guy who is a Meu tie
fighter and he was really like a high
level fighter and he decided to get a
sex change and then once you get a sex
change,
he literally,
he got his balls cut off,
stop producing testosterone and
started getting the fuck beat out.
No Shit.
He was still fighting men.
Oh,
he's still fighting men,
but they didn't have balls anymore.
So it's not exactly that.
This six foot tall person that was a man.
And I see what you're saying.
I'm a woman is a woman,
but it's not exactly that is a man either.
He's sort of in this weird limbo state.
Yeah.
But he still this unfair
mechanical advantage.
That's a giant person.
He's got huge shoulders,
huge hands.
If you're playing against a little girl,
that's just stupid.
Yeah.
Well,
and it is like those athletes then they
weren't they saying that the people that
had prosthetic limbs,
like the runners with those special,
you know what I mean,
those legs,
but they're like,
oh,
it's an unfair advantage.
So lucky to be criminal.
One guy made it in.
Well,
no,
I don't want,
I don't want to say that.
You know,
that anybody would be
lucky to be critical.
But they were saying that,
but I don't think they
were really saying that.
What they're really saying.
It's like,
realistically,
let's look at what's going on here.
There's a mechanical advantage to those
things that surpasses the human body.
Like these are springs.
You're running on these
crazy sprinting springs.
Right.
You know?
I mean,
those things work like a motherfucker.
So if they're really the,
it seems like they work better than legs.
Yeah.
That is one thing that
can happen for sure.
What goes on is you
cannot tear your Achilles.
Yeah.
It's like it literally,
you don't have one.
You can't,
you can't.
You can't tear your ACL
if it's up to your quad.
Yeah.
Well,
the whole thing is really,
I mean,
you would never want to say that
there's anyone that has any sort of an
advantage to being handy.
You know what I'm saying?
I mean,
it's a sensitive issue.
we're all very lucky that we're not.
Thank God.
Of course.
When you do see like that
you can run faster with that.
Like at what point in time do you let
that go off the world record becomes a guy
with
robot legs.
Right.
You know what I mean?
Like how do you define the athletics?
Like that guy was in the Olympics
this summer with prosthetics.
Remember that?
The spinner,
was he South African?
I don't know.
I forget where he was from.
I think he was,
but he,
um,
it was cool to see him in the event.
He didn't,
he didn't win or metal,
which made it less of an issue.
You know,
people didn't press it,
but they were pressing
it before he got in.
Everybody was,
people were saying that South African run.
Remember Africa was she,
she was both genders or
something and everyone was upset?
No.
Well that was,
people were accusing her of being,
um,
a hermaphrodite and they put her throat.
She at the end of the day,
no,
it's the shoes.
She's a woman.
But she was put through
like really brutal,
um,
exam.
I read the scrutiny.
Yeah.
And,
and they were people were
people definitely as a woman,
100%.
I'm,
I'm almost certain,
um,
I forget,
I just forgot her name
blanked on her name too,
but she is South African and uh,
yeah and the country,
they adore her because she was so,
yeah,
cause they were,
people really were,
were horrible to her like during the,
you know the scribe.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
But she's,
I'm fairly certain she's legitimately,
I mean if you go through the trouble of
of cotton your Peter off and doing all
that,
like just let the guy let the girl,
but that's not her.
Sure.
No problem is it's not
let her play basketball,
play basketball with a little girl.
What school does all these like
little girls that are playing there?
Like they just went to college.
The 18.
This is a 50 year old man.
That was crazy.
That one is crazy.
What school is he?
Is
this Lucy here?
Yes.
You're white.
You're right.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
You know,
God bless him his whole life.
He just wanted to be on the ladies' team.
What's happening?
Yes.
Sort of,
but it's not fair.
I mean it's just not,
the problem is once you start
having competitive athletics,
it's like ended.
But then the other thing in life,
it's do whatever you want to do.
If you want to go to work with a dress,
if you're nice,
I'll talk to you.
I don't know.
It was more of you to dress
like a man if you were,
you know,
whatever your fucking thing is.
If you're nice,
I don't care,
I'll talk to you I,
but when you have to recognize the
mechanical advantages to the male frame,
of course the tendon strength.
Even when there's a depletion
of testosterone and your
body showed us shrivels
up a little bit and then
you lose muscle mass.
It's still a God damn man.
And the overwhelming evidence
is if you look at men's verse,
if you line up men's and women's
results for athletic competition,
there's a,
there's a depth.
There's a reason why every single one,
basically the men are more
advanced and they're there,
they run faster,
jump higher,
but then you guys are going
to get like the anomalies,
like every now and then there is a woman
that can do as many pushups as the male
marines or whatever.
They have the same athletic standards.
But if you,
you might get a group of weak guys,
one really strong girl.
But if you have all the guys,
you have just the strongest
guys in the strongest girls.
Let's strong as Christ this.
There are fucking freaks out there.
Oh yeah.
I've seen some of these
guys in the UFC that fine.
Three,
four,
five rounds and don't
even get fucking tired.
Wow.
What kind of incredible shape.
Some of those fucking guys are amazing,
amazing.
Some high level shit.
And at that level that those men,
those like,
like the really high level men,
like there's nothing like that that when
women can't really keep up with that.
Oh,
you know,
and that's one of the,
the,
the big accusation against this one
woman who is like one of the top women in
the world.
She was stripped of her tire named Cyborg.
And she's built like,
she's built like a strong dude like Brian,
can you pull up a picture,
pull up,
pull up a picture of Cyborg muscular dude.
You wait,
wait to see how scary this.
And she fought this other chick,
Gina Carano and Gina Carano,
beautiful son of us.
I guess it has like a
famous football player,
you know,
beautiful,
smart,
tough chick.
And this Brazilian bitch
just ragdoll really horrific.
It was a vicious,
vicious beating.
But everybody accuses
her of doing steroids.
Okay.
So then she got caught.
She didn't get caught and she got caught.
She tested hot and when she tested hot,
everybody was like,
like,
I don't know,
that's one picture of her.
There's a,
there's some other pictures of her,
Brian,
like she's a celebrating
in the cage cause that's,
that's her at a way in.
And there's a difference
between you and a wagon and you,
um,
when you're actually fighting.
Cause when you're actually fighting,
that's when your muscles
pump up with blood.
Like we have one on the far right.
You see your Brian far IA right there.
Yeah.
Right there.
She looks like Kate from the
last mix with the sweetest.
Are you kidding me,
grandma?
Yeah.
Uh,
anyway,
in any way,
like Lauren Landry,
she's a very,
very muscular woman.
Jesus,
she's a tank and she's scary,
talented,
like the,
as a striker.
She's really,
she's for a woman.
She is fucking vicious.
It's so okay.
And as feminist as I totally am,
I,
there's some part of me that
I look at her and you're like,
why,
why sweet?
Well,
because she wants to go to war.
And I liked that and I respect that
because I too am an angry fucking,
but at the same time you're like,
oh,
I just want to protect her.
I don't want her to get her face head.
Oh,
she,
um,
she came up with the
craziest camp in Brazil.
There she is.
She came up with the shoot,
the shoot the box shoe box and a shoot.
The box camp is all these like
bad ass Brazilian Moy Thai guys.
They're fucking animals.
And uh,
she was married to the
other dude's Cyborg,
eventually sta.
And he's a,
he's a fucking lease too.
He's an old school and then a legend.
So the two of them were just
like the scariest Koppel ever.
And they breeding super babies.
I don't think they're together anymore.
She fortunately,
but yeah,
she is a,
she's terrifying woman.
Did you,
by the way,
did you get,
I told you I got to see a little bit of
the fights this weekend when I was in a,
in the hotel.
I was like,
I was in Calgary and uh,
I saw you on and then when a
brown beat Swick it was right.
Yeah.
Uh,
which was,
um,
yeah,
he was,
uh,
there's some great,
that was a most of the ground game fight.
If I remember.
It was,
uh,
I don't think they went to the,
well,
they went to the ground.
He got them in a dark and
then he almost got him,
I think he almost got him
at a triangle and the cars,
I thought,
uh,
Brown almost had him like
they would in the first round,
the first round,
and then the second one is stomped him.
Is that what happened or did they stop
him at the end of the first round?
Was that the first round?
I think it was,
I don't remember.
Whatever.
I don't remember when exactly it happened,
but mine knocked the sensational Knox.
Yeah.
Great.
Knock out.
Um,
but afterwards did,
did you know or did you
just see or they tell you,
uh,
when Brown was waiting for you and
like what Erin on Fox was that he was
standing there and he was looking around.
He was like,
Hey Joe.
what's up man?
Yeah,
cut to commercial.
Well,
he even said that to me.
Like he looked over at me.
It was totally not my call.
I didn't miss it.
When,
when,
if you see me in the cage or,
or,
or uh,
or not,
it's like,
it's not my call.
They tell me we want an interview or
they tell me there's no time for an
interview.
And a lot of times they
say there's no time.
And when you do a sh a like the Fox card,
like I think they were already worried
about time and it turned out to be a good
worry because of the,
the fight I believe started
after it was supposed to end.
So like for people that set their dvrs,
like they didn't even get to fight.
A lot of people didn't
get the fight apparently.
Oh No.
Yeah.
So that's why they were behind the time.
I don't understand like how
they produce a show like that.
I don't,
I don't really like even
go in the truck and peak.
Like I dunno what the fuck they're doing,
but I know that when you know
you have like live fight,
it's really difficult to judge
how much actual time you have.
It could be like three first round knock
outs or it could be three really long
decisions where or it can be three
decisions where a guy gets kicked in the
balls and you have to stop
the time for five minutes.
Like sometimes shit can drag on past
where you think it's going to be.
So they err on the side of caution and
they cut out interviews when they can.
Yeah.
Well you got to have much tighter time
restrictions on a network like Fox than
like a normal either.
You know,
obviously a paper view or
even like a cable thing.
Cause that's like hard out and ends for
other shows that you can't go late into.
Right.
Yeah,
I guess it is.
She just get walkie talkies between
that probably solve everything.
Talking to
the next fights on,
come on out.
You know who's talking?
No,
no you don't.
I don't think you know
what you're talking about.
Silly bitch
talking about like miss [inaudible] idea.
What we're saying
problem.
Why don't you go into your next
production meeting and be like,
I'm just going to bring him and he's going
to talk for me from you guys talking,
talking about the guys
getting kicked in the balls.
They have something to protect her.
Yeah,
they do.
They do.
But a lot of guys that
were the wrong cups,
if you just wear like a
regular jockstrap strap,
it's um,
there's like,
there's those things move around and
they're designed for like sports.
They're really not designed for dudes
kicking you in the things that you need
when someone's kicking you in the deck,
you need it
more comprehensive approach
has been a Titleist natural.
Yeah.
You can't be set off for
that softball bullshit
because those,
those kicks are hard as fuck inside
leg kicks that Dick or one of the most
painful things I ever,
oops.
So they're so horrible.
I'd been kicked in the balls so many times
because I've had,
I've probably had been kicked in the
balls at least a hundred times in my life.
Really hard.
It's amazing that they,
you can get through those.
I mean,
cause I worry about,
oh,
but always with a cup on.
Yeah.
Okay.
Well I don't think I've ever been
kicked without a cup that God,
oh my gosh.
Well there's videos about that.
Yeah.
It's the Cup protects
you a little bit caught,
protects you a little bit.
It keeps them from rupturing.
I think is what it is.
Oh yeah.
Guys have lost testicles because
they were sparring and they got
kicked and they didn't have a cup on.
Oh,
what about one of those?
Like people get like the,
the high heels and the balls.
How's that?
She doesn't have burst Burstows.
And you played the one before?
Um,
yeah,
I got that.
There's a video that shit's frightening.
There's some that are clearly faked.
Yeah.
Like you can be like,
oh,
they've got a cup on or whatever.
But then I have one,
I'll send it to you where they,
it starts,
she's kicking 'em really hard
and he's got underwear on.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's in Spanish.
And then she just like,
suffer,
suffer.
I want you to suffer.
And you're like,
all right.
But maybe he has a cup on.
Then she takes the underwear
off and she fucking,
she's like punting a football
kicking out like Bam.
And He is like,
what heals on his knees are
shaking and he starts to bleed.
He starts bleeding.
Oh my God.
He's just taking it
like London's likes it.
Right.
She squeezes so hard.
Some grill over.
She's saying Spanish.
You bleed.
Yes.
Macro.
Unnecessary.
Oh,
I know.
Tell her to stop.
Then when I saw as she
was taking the healing,
she was grinding it like a cigarette,
but after our rainy day,
grinding it into this concrete,
that's what she was doing
his balls with high heels on.
What is it?
How could someone want that?
I don't know.
What is what?
What is the switch that
goes wrong in your,
I don't think where you
want someone to hurt you.
He's dirty balls.
I hate them
healthy.
They can even would want it.
I don't think they even
think they want it.
I do it.
I think they something with
leads them to discover it.
Not that they want it,
but they're like,
oh,
my reaction to that is not
what most people go through,
which is like,
God,
that's the worst thing ever.
All of a sudden they get that and some
something happens inside where it's like
they get a rush,
some type of adrenaline,
and then they're like,
oh wow,
that there's a pleasure to write.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah,
I think so.
Scrubber thing,
isn't it an s and m thing?
It's being submissive
watching one right now.
You guys,
me scared.
There we go.
Look at John the TV.
I don't think you're
allowed to show this now.
You can't show balls,
dude.
Now it,
it's blurred out.
Oh is it really for real?
Like he has it spread out like it looks
like a frog on a Ustream is our friend.
Just kidding.
We can't get him in trouble high.
He'll commercial though.
Um,
you ever listened to Dan Savage?
He has the savage love podcast.
He's a sex columnist and he says that
those fetishes come from your childhood.
Like let's say if you've got a,
a fetish for raincoats.
When you were a little kid,
you associated some
pleasure with your rain rye.
Like you'd rub against it and maybe
that gave you a boner and then later in
life,
that's what she associates
your sexual needs.
A latex can,
right?
So maybe this kid got kicked in the balls
when you use like a little boy by like
a little girl that he liked or something.
Whoa.
How many dudes have gotten
kicked in the balls by girls.
They like to the point
where it became a thing.
I wasn't possible.
How?
How is it possible that so many dudes
became turned on by that idea of getting
it every fetish guy model guys story.
When I was four,
I got kicked in the balls by Molly
turned me like a Werewolf
and I came a ball kick.
Fetishist totally.
That's got to hurt you.
What?
I don't understand it.
It's so painful.
I can't imagine that
anybody would want it.
Well,
I always feel so tentative
handling Tommy's nuts.
That's so nice.
Gentle and sweet and the
thought of hurting them.
And I asked for a little more.
I could give him a little tug.
A little something.
Did you know that?
Uh,
the size of a man's testicles,
the sides of the humans testicles is
proportionate to the promiscuity of the
women in his surrounding
area was all primates.
That the size of the testicles rises
and falls depending on how big a hooker
your the girls from your neighbor?
No,
my dad must've group Breslin real sluts.
Then
my dad's [inaudible]
talking about last night,
I was like,
I saw him,
uh,
I went into his room and he was like,
I think he was putting on underwear.
So from behind I go,
Jesus Christ man.
And he was like,
what could you get like donkey nuts?
He's like,
all right Tommy [inaudible] so
he must have been a real horse.
It's probably his g not necessarily him,
but you know the generations
before him that made him,
you know,
it's like it becomes a genetic thing
and it all comes from being around more
promiscuous women.
That's why chimps have the biggest balls,
seven normous ball cause Dick's
aren't even as big as ours
cause female chimps like way bigger.
Their balls are so big.
Yeah,
chimps are down to fuck all day.
What's the other monkey
and actual cousin that the chimp,
it's a,
it's a separate type of champ.
Oh yeah.
They don't just masturbate.
They do everything except mother and son.
Mother,
mother and son is the only,
I think
they don't do.
Yeah.
And we were talking about that on the
podcast is that someone had speculated
that that might,
because they had figured out that there
was like bad things happen to the baby
when the mother has sex.
Figured it out basically.
Maybe,
but the problem with that is
that they're fucking all day.
They're fucking everybody.
You wouldn't have to like
really be sure to kind of,
they use sex as a social tool.
Yes.
Smooth over differences.
Homosexual sex.
Yeah,
they do.
They just show the,
and they just fucking each other.
They go crazy and they are like,
they're very rarely
violent with each other.
It's really fascinating.
But yeah,
for sure.
Definitely.
But it's amazing how that evolved.
Like how does that evolve?
It's incredible.
It's weird.
How do you get to a point where you gotta
like this Weird Society of like loving
chimps?
It just fuck all the time.
Then we look at them like they're sick.
Right?
Right.
They're the oldest
primates that we know of,
but don't kill each other or
don't kill each other a lot.
I mean,
maybe,
you know,
there's probably some aberrations even
in the Bonobo world where some shit goes
down,
right?
Someone's got to regulate.
Yeah.
Banabos decks don't work.
No.
I heard somewhere that before we had
traditional marriage that it actually made
sense for the woman to bang his many
dudes in the village so that the paternity
of her children was unknown and she'd
actually have more men to protect the
offspring.
Like that to me would make
sense if I had all of you guys,
right,
Tommy Red Banjo and that guy
all doing me and then right.
I make a baby.
Whose baby is it?
Logan's going to defend it and yeah,
I'll have to take care of my babies.
They become community babies.
If you guys want to set that up,
Mckenna,
Terence Mckenna,
the sinks to the bottom,
Terence Mckenna always thought that in
our distant history that it's likely that
we had these polygamous groups of
people that like did psychedelic drugs
together.
Like his idea of like the long
forgotten paradise was like these,
you know,
back where he believed like,
civilization was first being created
and he believes that those civilizations
that came up,
they were all just eating mushrooms,
tripping their balls off
and fucking each other.
Right.
Yeah.
And then Club Med came,
is that,
that took a long time.
I think your timeline,
it might be a little bit off,
but that sounds like a fun time,
but that Mccain was world.
But this idea was that at one time there
was enough people doing ego suppressing
things like he eating mushrooms,
like they,
it's all like really speculative.
There's the idea of trying to figure out
how many different cultures we're doing
psychedelic drugs when they
came up with their religion,
when they came up with a lot
of their ideas about life and,
and,
uh,
you know,
studying the cosmos,
like a lot of those cultures that
really got heavily into that stuff.
We're also really heavily
into psychedelic drugs.
Like the Mayans,
like making their crazy fucking calendars.
The Mayans did a lot of mushrooms,
man,
I didn't know that.
Oh yeah,
they mushrooms and raw chocolate together.
There's a,
there's some,
some plant that had
like an LSD like effect.
They also took this,
I don't remember what it was,
but the idea,
I went on a tour of Cheech and needs.
So with this guy who was a
professor and it was a really cool,
like you can hire him as a guide
and he was so knowledgeable,
man.
It was just really interesting.
Yeah.
You know,
him talking about all the,
the different traditions and why this
was created and that was created.
But he had the,
he took me to this room and he's like,
this is where they did their,
their rituals.
They,
they,
you know,
and taking some sort of a
psychedelic plant that had an Lsd,
like a fact,
like this was just like a
culture of super duper trippers.
Yeah.
Well,
when you see the right,
when you see what they built,
you're like,
you did not have been sound mind when
you came up with not logical.
Not at all.
He got to some weird places,
weirder than anybody where they,
they fucking killed people so
often that they had like spots.
Like we're going to kill him right here.
This is the altar they had alters
where they would sacrifice.
Be Sure I saw one,
I didn't,
not in Mexico.
I went to a,
in Peru,
I went to Machu Picchu a couple
of times and they had the,
like a sacrificial room they showed you.
They would like on this table,
people would voluntarily be sacrificed.
Let's see,
utilities that you have to
be high as fuck for a thing.
Is that the point to satisfy the gods?
Take a virgin?
Are you taking so strong?
There was a period in um,
uh,
when the Aztecs,
when they,
uh,
when they killed 80,000 people,
some,
some insane number of people over like a,
just a period of four
days when there was one,
one of the temples that
was being built there.
They apparently,
this is like,
it's been,
it's disputed whether or not they
killed 80,000 or whether they killed,
you know,
whether it was only really
10,000 people exaggerated.
Like there's some dispute as to how
many people were actually killed.
But if the number there
they believe is 80,000,
she,
and this was said in 1487,
the Aztec King,
uh,
he,
and when,
when they completed one of their,
uh,
their pyramids,
he killed every prisoner that like was,
was part of the construction.
Oh yeah.
So they like,
they fucking built this shit for free,
built this shit for him.
And then he kills some insane amount
of people over the course of four days.
But that's a lot of voluntarily dying to,
you know,
I don't know.
I think so.
This was not,
it was so crazy that like Duncan
told me about this first and then,
um,
I read it and I couldn't believe it.
And then I told a bunch
of different people,
I go,
did you know that this happened?
And I've had people go,
fuck it.
Did.
No,
it didn't like walk like
totally incredulous.
Walk away from me and I let us send them,
I've had to send them emails
like that when I won that,
that hunting show.
Yeah.
It was Steve Vanilla.
Great Guy.
Man,
really,
but really intelligent guy.
Very well read guy.
And I told him about it.
He didn't believe it either and he's like,
there's no way.
I'm like,
I'm telling Ya,
I'll,
I'll send you the thing.
When you send someone to the,
the actual,
you know,
the different stories
and depictions of this,
this time and the 14 hundreds and you
see that number 80,000 can you even wrap
your head around?
You're not doing this with guns folks.
Okay.
Wrap your head around 80,000
people getting cut to death.
Fucking the Rose Bowl in
four fucking slaughtered.
Oh my gosh.
Is everybody has their
throats and they're heart
pulled out of their chests.
Dude is nuts.
What a Co Raisie motherfucker.
Yeah,
that is,
that's insane.
Yeah.
They yard,
they took shit to the next level.
Again,
massive mushroom meters.
Trippers bid time.
Trippers.
It's weird when you combine like a,
a lot of the,
the interesting things
about those cultures,
a lot of the interesting discoveries,
there's very strange use of like an UN
hieroglyphic like language and it took us
a long time to figure out if
they still work on some of the,
the,
the different,
more complex character
things in order and debate.
Like what exactly it means.
Like there,
there's a great documentary,
I think it's from Nat Geo
called decoding the Maya,
I believe that's what it's called and
it's really interesting to see these guys,
these scholars trying to figure
out what the fuck this was.
It's crazy language.
Well the other thing that blows your
mind every time if you see something mine
as tech or the Incas is that
when you see what they built,
you can take today's greatest
architect and be like,
how would you do this here?
And they don't even like,
I don't even know where to start,
but how these things were built perfectly
constructed and stones that way,
like 20 times are laid on top of
another stone and fits into it.
They have theories.
They're like,
well,
we think that they would
pour water down here.
And then you're like,
how many people would
it take to move this?
And they're like,
oh,
like 8,000.
And then we probably put it over.
And you're like,
none of it makes sense.
Anybody that like there's,
there's,
there's a people that will
try to debunk anything.
Anytime you bring up anything that
seems even remotely paranormal,
you know,
like,
hey,
like ghosts or fuck on the aliens here,
anything you remotely parent,
they automatically try to go block.
There's no,
there's no evidence for that.
There's no that's all well and
good till you get to giant stones.
And there's something about moving.
Giant stones are like,
listen man,
you got to explain this.
You got to explain that.
You can't just say,
oh well they did that.
And uh,
you know,
they,
they figured it out and they cut
it out of this quarry right here.
Look,
we have one.
There's one of my favorite pieces of
evidence is would they show this one,
um,
one of these giant
fucking pig stone pillars.
They were carving out of this,
uh,
this one giant piece of granite and they
stopped in the middle of the carving.
But because of the fact that it
was like partially completed,
you could see the method of shaping it.
Yeah.
It was really kind of interesting.
Like they,
they learned a lot from that.
So they believe that they did it with
stones and they believe that they did it
slowly.
Like it was a real painstaking process
of slowly chipping away to get these,
but how the fuck
did they move?
You gotta tell me how they move.
There's no cranes,
no bulldozers.
Yeah.
We to assume
that they had some incredible knowledge
of leverage and moving things and they
figured out how to get things under it
and leverage it and move it somehow.
But to pretend that that's not a
mystery is really kind of disingenuous.
The day.
I find that,
I mean also to human thinking changes
over time and since the enlightened
imminent period and like
the scientific revolution,
we discredited anything that's
remotely Ooky and mysterious
because there's so much
ooky mysterious stuff.
That's bull shit.
Yeah.
It's such a problem.
There's so much bullshit out there.
Whether it's ghost
bullshit or Ufo bullshit.
There's so many nutty motherfuckers
with fake bigfoot stories.
Yeah.
Just muddying up the waters.
Right.
That's true.
Bull Shit.
Yeah.
So a course,
a smart person is going to gravitate
towards the scientific and more likely
explanation.
Yeah.
Almost everything that's very,
but it's not explaining everything.
That's the thing is,
is leading.
It's leaving things that are,
that are valid.
You know,
not the bullshit story.
It was leaving the real thing also
like unexplored or unexplained and,
and people just go like,
man,
whatever.
Well with science can't figure out his
emotions and our org and why do we like
beautiful things and why?
Why do I love hearing certain songs?
Why has it changed the way my body feels?
You know,
what does it feel like to the,
to kiss somebody that you love?
Is that really just a bunch of chemicals?
It's floating around in your brain?
What is going on there?
What can science measure that?
You know,
the,
the emotional,
human aspect of life is
the one thing that science,
Canton,
we're really truly defined yet,
but who knows?
Man,
we might be able to break it down one day
to ones and Zeros and you just program
the,
the right ones and Zeros in your
head and you're happy all the time.
Let's do it just goes keep dreaming.
Men Stream all day.
You ever talked to someone like who has
a problem with like normal consciousness
and they need something like an Ssri or
something like that and then when they
take it they talk about how like they,
they finally can like see life.
We're going to be able to
engineer that in people like,
yeah,
I mean I guess we're doing it right now,
but people taking pills,
the meat and the cheese of it.
Well,
the,
well,
the levels of certain things that make,
you know,
your,
your consciousness operate certain
things like serotonin and dopamine,
like the levels of these things like
how these things are produced by them,
they're going to be able
to manipulate that shit.
Oh yeah.
And they're going to be building
to manipulate your mood.
Like you're going to be like way happier.
You're also okay
be able to program or
there'll be able to program,
um,
the genes that are more desirable
and leave out things that are not.
Yeah.
Well that's one of the
things I always felt like,
if you look at those,
the,
the standard image of the alien,
you know,
the gray I,
the gray can big idea alien.
They're like real flimsy bodies that big,
big,
giant heads.
If you look at,
and you look at us and
you look at a gorilla,
they look more like us than the gorilla.
Okay.
Yeah,
they do.
Right?
Yeah.
Like that might be what we're gonna do.
We're gonna get,
get rid of all the whole sex
organ thing and just going to,
yeah,
we're going to design these
like bulletproof bodies
that can see through walls
and we're just going to take that on.
They had and we're going to repeat it.
Well,
I think there's going to be able to figure
out a way to manipulate your genetics
and there's never going to
be a dumb kid born again.
Sure.
Or develop a new language to dumb people
and your fucking kids going to be five
going,
hey,
stupid.
Okay,
why are you doing
fucking super genetic freak kid,
right?
Five [inaudible] village.
Three languages will stop speaking
English at this point or any real
and that'll mean that everything will
just communicate with our consciousness.
We don't even have to speak anymore.
I wouldn't how much different the
world would be if we all had the same
language.
It makes a huge difference.
I wonder how much do you know
confusion when it comes to like,
especially like,
well,
things like that are going on.
Excuse me.
Since they're going on in the Middle East.
You know,
we,
I don't,
I don't speak Israeli.
I don't speak Hebrew.
I don't,
I dunno,
I dunno what the Palestinians are saying.
I don't know what the Saudis are saying.
I know what the Iranians are saying.
I can't hear,
hear that.
I don't understand it.
Sorry.
See,
you're reliant on someone like have you
ever seen like some of the translations
that were uh,
that were attributed to aqua,
a jod the a,
is that his name?
The A to come in and then a job.
There's like,
people take like things out of context
that he said and make it like much more
inflammatory.
I mean,
he says plenty of inflammatory shit,
but they manipulate things
and we don't know about that.
We don't know about that
unless you really go and look.
And if he talked English,
we would know,
oh yeah,
fucker loans
radians and fucking
listen to this podcast.
And I ran like,
bitch,
I thought you were cool.
Here's the thing too
is that hitting folks,
it always universal language.
We should learn Farsi.
There you go.
Universal language.
It always blows my mind too because it
brings to the point when people say the
word fluent when they say they're fluent
in another language and you realize
what it really means to be fluent because
people can speak a lot of a language
and still miss tons of things,
misunderstand things
and definitely not true.
Like I speak pretty damn good Spanish
from growing up in a Spanish speaking
household and I've seen,
I've watched,
uh,
like court shows where they
have an interpreter for
somebody and I've been like,
that's not what he said.
And that like the person said it,
you know,
like that.
I've watched translations like
UN things where you'll be like,
oh,
that person speaks,
let's say fluent Spanish.
And you think you're like,
no,
they speak great English too,
but it's actually like they speak 90%
good English and can miss a word and
intention the it can be shuffled
around and that when you miss it,
when you misunderstand something
by a word or I'll have it,
you know,
in Spanish we're all like you.
You think I'm pretty much on point,
but you missed just a little thing,
a little detail that you don't miss
when it's either your native language or
you're so immersed in a language
that you truly are fluent in it,
right?
You are,
you're thinking while you're talking.
Oh yeah.
And like,
you know,
I mean if you live in a,
in a,
in a country where if you live
in your second language country,
you can overtime I think
really speak tremendous,
whatever that language might be.
You know what I mean?
Like once you lit,
when you're surrounded by that language,
24 seven but short of that,
like you really do miss things
and then you let them saying,
that's also what leads to
misunderstandings lead to argument.
And he's a neat leads to confrontation
and violent sometimes because you
misunderstood something.
It wasn't even a disagreement.
You just say it right or understand it,
right?
Yeah.
There's a,
apparently there's a new app and it,
you can talk to it and if you're
talking and whatever language,
it translates it back to you
in real time and English.
Wow.
Yeah.
I haven't,
do you know what I'm talking about Brian?
No,
I had no idea.
Yeah.
Have you heard of this?
No.
Goddamn and I have to find about this.
I have to Google search it now because,
um,
somebody told me about it
and I haven't looked into it,
but this is apparently
something and either they're
working on and it's going to
be released soon or it's out now.
Um,
like with my parents who are Hungarians
speakers and I can understand stuff,
but even when I speak
to my father in English,
right?
Like he has a whole different
understanding of English,
of course,
as I do in a different continent.
When he speaks Hungarian,
I still don't really understand because
of the different time and space that we
grew up learning a language in like even
generational between your father who is
American,
like you didn't grow up with the
same TV shows that you did or no.
The same references that you can almost,
you can misunderstand each other.
Even then this act,
this is a real thing.
Okay.
It's an APP that translates languages
during real time phone calls.
Wow.
So you can call someone and you can be
talking to someone and in real fucking
time,
whatever they say in French or Spanish
two translates it to you in realtime.
Wow.
That's incredible.
That's nuts.
Yeah.
We should,
but we don't know any
other anglers languages,
so we would know if I can
call it Japanese girl.
No,
you don't know shit.
Have you ever been to kings,
a Taiwan website?
Have you,
did you see that Twitter did today?
No.
Kings of Taiwan.
I was this,
I was on Amazon last night looking up
books and it said like where it says
recommends to you and one
was recommends to you.
Uh,
Tie Taiwan,
hookers and I,
it was a kindle book.
Why?
And so I like what the fuck is this book?
And I started reading through
it and then I was like,
oh wait,
this is from a website.
Somebody just took it and
made it a book on Amazon.
So then I started going on this website
and next thing I know I'm looking deep
into this like report of how
to get hookers and Taiwan
and how there's like it's
accepted there and how
it is so interesting.
But then I found myself like on Orbitz,
like how expensive is it
going to get a Taiwan,
but what am I doing about going to Taiwan?
I was lost.
I was lost on,
sometimes you just get lost in
that barrel on the Internet,
you know,
you just not really keep on going fall
down that hole man that you were thinking
about action going to Taiwan.
It looked really nice.
I was looking at videos on youtube and
it looked like really pretty there and
stuff and then people were saying
it's like it's better than Vegas.
It's like way better than Vegas
prison just for smoking pot.
Oh No,
no.
Just don't do drugs or anything.
I follow the rules.
They have articles on that website
about all the laws there and what to do,
where to stay and what's soapies to get.
Who has the youngest?
Angela?
It's a soapy.
Soapy.
So you guys never been in Taiwan?
No,
no yet.
We're planning on going for the,
for the Vegas experience
for the better.
It's really hard to get
people leave the country.
Yeah.
Especially now.
You know,
like,
but if you're looking for a place
where really good hookers do it,
man,
we're not the world champs
and report back to us
by no means.
I meant more just for the night life.
It seems like if they,
it was just seems crazy though.
Uh,
we,
um,
yeah,
we've Sung that song.
I love the,
uh,
we just had Yoshi on
our show for the ocean.
A man I've seen too much.
He called,
he,
he believes in,
in strictly the hooker experience.
Oh,
poor Yoshi.
Yoshi is our friend.
Frankfurt is great.
And so it was a Amsterdam for,
is that in Germany?
That is,
Yoshi is a standup comedian
friend of ours who,
uh,
always worked for porn companies.
Yeah.
So we would be at the
comedy store and Yoshi was,
she would go,
she would roll up with like,
I'll box of [inaudible].
I was always giving you oh,
agent sensation and check it.
I'll take a DVD
stuff to beat off to.
Oh,
actually we did for a long
part of my collection.
It was secondhand Yoshi DVDs that Yoshi
had given people that they take and
shit.
That's hilarious.
Yeah.
That fetish stuff.
Strange as fuck.
Like dude.
So like jerk off on girl's feet and shit.
Weirdness
in glasses and drives all I'd be
like here and all over the glasses,
which is like,
ah,
you got it on my glasses.
I can't,
I'll try to go back to reading now.
And then they would always try to either.
Next sentence.
My friend got out,
she does bondage stuff and she just got
a letter the other day that was like,
Hey,
you know,
I want to be your gimp.
Uh,
I just
can't,
you know,
I have to wear a mask,
but you can like peel off pieces of
my arm and eat it if you want to.
You could do anything you want to.
The person that you know,
she said that to you wrote a letter,
an email to this person I know.
Oh,
okay.
And it was like this,
any scent attached a photo and
it's so horrible to look at.
You look at it and go,
wow,
that's,
that's a serial killer right there.
That guy right there as a cigarette.
You know what they say about people
that have like this thing where they're
always hurting themselves.
I like terrible like
cut themselves or pin,
you know,
like some people like have like crazy,
like genital piercings and shit like that.
They think that some people that do like
really freaky shit might have a problem
with a not experiencing
pain the right way.
Oh,
that's interesting.
They really,
yeah.
And it leads to more and more extreme,
uh,
you know,
things to like really jolt
themselves and feel it.
Well,
some people clearly don't have the same
pain threshold that like I would say the
majority of people have.
You see some people do
things and you're like,
how the fuck did that not
hurt you more than anything?
Well you know that guy that
got fucked death by the Horse?
Yeah.
That guy,
that guy had,
that guy had piercings all over his balls.
His balls were like a three ring binder.
I'm not joking.
You just click,
click,
click.
It's all like this guy was,
he was a straight up loke stir.
It wasn't just getting horses
to fuck him in the ass.
He was like run metal
through his ball bag.
Horses,
horses,
grazing.
That horse fucked him to death.
The craziest thing too about the horse
fucking and then being into that is the
Horse Dick is second to the horse
thrust because an animal thrust,
a thrust from a horse is
in the hospital cancer.
You could line up eight
people and be like,
don't let him push and
that was so fucking,
yeah man.
All they eat is grass too.
What the fuck?
Yeah,
I can imagine of grasses or solution.
The whole time.
Everything.
Healthiest fucking just
run for a hundred miles.
Horses he grasps in.
They're yoked.
Yeah.
There's so swollen.
Any animal more swollen.
A horse.
I was about to say if they're
like thoroughbreds and
then I remembered they are
like
thoroughbred horse,
like there's no animal in the
animal kingdom that is more like,
and they're fucking beautiful.
Yeah.
You see them,
you're like,
that looks like I'm a Jessica.
The fact that you can actually ride it
and get it to do shit with you on its
back.
It's like,
how's 35 miles an hours down?
You know?
Like we didn't know the
real problem though.
It's like the people that want to do
those like jumping things and you know all
that other kind of crazy
shit with the horses.
Like those sports,
they can stream sports.
People die during those times.
That's how Christopher you've got fucked
up and the horses get fucked up a lot
too.
Yeah.
I don't get that.
I just feel like,
you know,
that's a scary proposition right there.
You're,
you're planning on this
animal listening to you.
What if it pulls a muscle?
Yeah.
Are you ready for that?
That shit.
If you understand like bodies,
you know the animals,
the strain things,
they break legs,
they twist ankle shit goes wrong.
If Shit's going wrong while
that animal does that,
you're attached to that fucking thing
and it's going to spike you into the
ground with all of its
weight on top of you.
Yeah Dude.
Fuck riding a horse.
Buck riding a horse.
I got bucked virtual knuckles.
Girl,
I'm with you.
Fuck that.
Look,
I think they're beautiful and I wouldn't,
I wouldn't mind writing
horse like a trail horse and stuff like
that as long as I guess cool horse that
some guy had hadn't tooken care of.
Like you know that this is like uh,
an easy going hoarse.
It's always been loved treating those
respect who's been hanging out years.
I'm totally down with that.
But the real,
the real problem is
he's fucking a question.
Events.
We've got jumping over shit.
Ooh,
for this beautiful,
magnificent beast.
I mean short of it is kind
of cool to watch the jump.
It is,
but I mean it have respect.
Like you said,
this animal,
he also has a mind of its own.
How do you know what it's going to do?
It wants to do that bullshit.
It doesn't want to do that.
Especially cause the animal can clearly
see that there is nothing to the left of
this fucking boards and
nothing to the right.
It's like,
why am I jumping?
And I've seen that.
I've seen that on,
I've seen footage of that before
where the horse goes like,
stop stupid.
Why am I jumping this man?
What am I?
You're fucking,
we got trained.
We got options.
I'm going round.
Why should I jump you on my back
jumping contest?
Just us.
Who Do you think of jumps highest?
The highest.
Brian,
are you rolling?
Are you broken today?
Something broken you because
it gave me that joint,
whatever the fuck was [inaudible]
do you have a good verdict?
Cool.
Um,
I could probably jump decent.
Not like nothing happening
is the one of all like the,
you know,
the physical things and,
and,
and attributes that you can desire.
Like,
I wish I could do this,
or you know,
when I remember with somebody,
especially if they're your size and
they have an amazing vertical leap,
it's the fucking most fascinating thing
to watch them to watch it because it's
totally natural.
Like I've been with people my height,
they can literally jump 15
inches higher than I can.
You just like Holy Shit.
And it's the thing,
I was like,
man,
and it is not from,
and the people that I've seen to do it
wasn't through like about training every
day,
but it was just,
that's how high I can jump.
I jump all day.
No,
it was just a natural,
hereditary like were whatever.
They were just born being able
to jump through the fucking roof.
And I think it's the person,
that's what Bo Jackson was like.
That's one of the most amazing
physical specimens in recorded time.
Jackson,
he's still got records
and the NFL combine.
I think he still holds the
record for the 40 does he?
I don't think so.
Watching that guy.
So that was like watching
a human horse like that.
It really was.
That guy is an unbelievable athletes
by somebody who wrote a book about him,
was talking about,
I wish I could remember the guy's name,
I should Google it,
watch,
look up Bo Jackson highlights from,
from football when he
was at Auburn or when he,
when he played for the,
if he didn't get his hip injured.
There is absolutely no telling
what that guy would have done.
He would fucking,
he was so fast that he was like,
you know,
he was like the fastest guy on the team,
but it was on like a 225 or 230 pound
body so he could trust people to like just
lower his shoulder and just,
he would deliver hits,
you know,
he'd give a concussion out
with the football in his hand.
Wow.
That just unbelievable physical specimen
bojack's in Christ and he played
professional baseball just
because he liked baseball too.
You know,
just one of those guys who was like,
oh,
how about I'll also play
another professional sport,
be Aussie,
but yeah,
and be awesome at it and just,
just home runs.
I remember watching him.
Here's,
see a guy,
because I saw him do this for sure.
There's footage of this Bo
Jackson breaking a baseball
bat over his boyfriend's
name and like you would
do it like it was nothing.
It lives like a twig man.
He like blew up like it
was breaking a candy bar.
Be like you have half of,
I'll take half.
Like he would just snap that shit.
Fuck.
I struck out,
apparently he was always
able to do freaky shit.
This guy was talking about
that when he was young.
He used to be able to jump over cars.
He gets jumped over the hood of a car.
I saw a guy do that too.
That's crazy.
Was that's like one of
the things I was talking.
I saw a guy do that who
was smaller than me,
shorter than me.
You know,
a total fucking just yoked dude.
He played running back.
He actually broke California state
records in high school and he did that.
He jumped over the hood
of a car and I was like,
that is amazing to watch.
I mean amazing and crazy to watch a
guy like that sprint and you're like,
oh dude,
I could run forever and
never sprint like that.
She does.
Yeah.
There's a kid that I saw on a
video who jumped off a roof,
did a back flip off a roof and it was
like a three story or two story building
was the most ridiculous
shit I've ever seen.
And the kid made it and
lived in it was fine.
If you want to see like that,
that's incredible.
If you want to see like a crate,
like a crazy other level like type of
athlete meaning athlete like you just see
like Oh said another gear that they have.
The other people just don't have.
If you look at um,
there's this guy that
plays football for like a,
he plays for the bills I think now his
name's Cj spiller and when he was at
Clemson,
there's highlights of him
like where he would stop,
like stop in the middle of the field and
there's like five guys surrounding him
and he just turns it on again.
But he goes to like,
he goes like fifth gear
before they get to first.
You know,
that's like,
he's to his gear so much faster than them.
But those are all like dynamite.
Yeah.
You know,
and you're just like that.
That doesn't make sense.
Like are like Devin Hester is this
guy who he plays for the bears.
He's like,
you know,
well,
well known returner and if
you watch his highlights,
the thing about him is that he hits,
they say like there are guys who
have faster 40 times than him,
but he hits his highest speed immediately.
Wow.
So it's like he gets the
ball and then he's just like,
here I'm running as fast as I can.
The first second I have the ball.
Whereas everybody else has to stop.
Yeah.
And you just like,
Holy Shit.
He is like,
he just,
he hit fifth gear immediately
and you see the other guy
that's a gate explosions.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
There's,
yeah,
there's,
there's no even playing field.
The idea that this uneven playing field
when it comes to human beings is crazy.
Yeah.
Just by looking at the
different sizes of us.
There's a reason why
we need weight classes.
Okay.
And the variables inside
of weight classes,
those are also pretty
extreme with some athletes.
Some people just aren't that coordinated.
They don't move that well,
they don't have that kind of power.
And then there's guys that can just learn
things like immediately and they can
run like a gazelle and they can do
shit to you that you can't do to them.
And they were out of the box like that.
Yeah.
You know,
there's,
there's guys that are
out of the box athletes.
If you were thinking about how
unlikely the total
package of Lebron James,
that's crazy.
That like that is a 0.001% like package
a critical date gives birth to him.
Yes.
His mom really crash.
Not only is his momma crackhead,
his mom allegedly was
fucking one of his teammates.
Oh,
that's right.
That's true.
Uh,
hot sauce in that bag.
The latte West,
is that true?
Yes.
Delonte west man,
his wife,
his allegedly had a
substance abuse problem.
Okay.
She gives birth to this
gigantic super athletes.
Amazing.
Who moves like a panther,
like a giant panther,
you know,
if that,
if Lebron James was an MMA,
do you know how many people
that got would be fucking up?
Oh yeah.
If you train that guy and that guy wanted
to fight if he had the will to fight.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
in high school he was all state
tied and playing football.
Cause people always talk about,
can you imagine this time?
But when it's playing football,
he stopped playing.
I think after his sophomore season
it was all state like already.
Like this can be somebody you're gonna
have to deal with and stop playing.
But you look at that body six,
eight,
two 70 [inaudible] your body
toward and learn how to fight.
Oh,
right.
What time did play football
this whole time with Jesus,
Lebron James Basketball.
It's just whatever Tom tells me.
If you don't watch
anything outside of that.
No,
I like tennis.
I used to about like ladies golf.
Do you still
have that day isn't gay come on?
Is that the case that I've
heard that said before?
What's that ladies?
Golf is like a lot of uh,
k checks.
I think there's a little bit of support.
100% yeah,
of course.
Always do.
But there's definitely
get the sticks they use.
There's definitely,
this is trying today.
There's definitely loves anger is Twitter.
That's what it is.
I like the came here and my Twitter.
I don't know who watches ladies' golf.
I'm not sure what the,
they are amazing offers that are golfers.
So essentially just a bunch of
Lesbos around staring at each other.
It's amazing how good they are though.
Fuck man.
Well,
it's one of the few groups that
lesbians available to really grow.
Like lesbians can't,
they have a hard time getting a community,
you know,
like gay dudes have massive
communities all over the country.
There's parts of the tenderloin and
if you go to the Santa Monica area,
West Hollywood,
Santa Monica Boulevard area,
there are days they've,
they've,
they've all can go on rated.
They know where the party's at.
Yeah,
the but then fucking that place
on Hollywood boulevard though.
The west side,
Santa Monica Boulevard,
West Hollywood spot.
That is the gay spot on earth.
Sorry,
which one?
Let's study area.
That whole area while you
drive in Santa Monica,
is that,
is that club rage still there?
Is it a five?
I don't go every week.
That's the flagship club.
That's the one that's on the big,
that was the one that I think,
you know we're Dakini is w I was coming
down though and I'm at the red light
there and it was a Saturday night and
it was fucking beautiful weather and
everybody was out and it leaves
a gay party on the streets,
man.
Yeah.
There's these two dudes and
they both have their hands,
their fingers looped into
each other's a belt loops.
Right.
And they were like in a lot,
because I kind of scissoring and
just grinding Dick's together.
It was like I can only wash is a certain
amount of time before some days slips
and I gotta get Outta here like this.
It was,
it was like a fucking bomb had been,
you know,
I did and I had to get
outside of the blast radius
bomb here,
but they're so happy.
They're happy as fuck
joy.
Well,
we used to live next to a
bear bar in silver lake,
so you'd have to walk past the bear bar,
the best get to trader Joe.
Whoa.
That's a specific type
of game is so wonderful.
And so like,
you know,
Tuesday nights is like job Tuesdays,
job Tuesday,
big sign out front.
It's rem job Tuesdays and they had a huge
rooster in the bag and like these guys
just party.
You'd hear like you drive by,
it could be,
you could have be having
like the like the most quiet,
lame kind of night and you're like,
there's nothing going on.
Yeah.
Then as you pulled up,
you're like,
Ooh.
You're like,
oh,
there's the decline.
And like you're like,
ah,
neighborhood is alive,
right?
Yeah.
And
the best part,
there was a security guard
that would stand out,
but because he was in front of a gay bar,
you didn't know if it was just a costume.
First few times I was
going on out tonight and he's like,
no,
I'm the security guy.
He had a mustache,
mustache,
very few.
The pull off the John Stossel
fat thick upper monsters.
We commit to that strange.
Well that's how I always wonder that
because people usually mock the mustache.
No,
are,
they rocked the ironic mustache,
but in the gay community it's like,
Yo,
I'm down for you.
I saw a guy the other day,
it was beautiful.
He had timberlands on and he had
cut off Jean shorts and he had like,
uh,
like uh,
one of those leather scally cap song
and he had a Jean jacket that was
sleeveless.
Nice.
He was fucking,
that's like,
this was like right after
I worked in San Francisco,
San Francisco with Greg Fitzsimmons.
Greg Fitzsimmons fucking killed me.
He,
he got on stage and he goes,
this is the last city
where there's real faggot
leather pants and a handlebar mustache.
It fucking crushed too.
Cause it was so true.
He's unabashed animals.
That's fun and funny.
That guy that you described,
like if,
if,
if cock was a company that's the chairman
and CEO of cock in charge with the
fluffy socks,
you know,
the style.
Yeah.
Scrunched down and the
timberlands like open.
And then he's got cutoff Jean
shorts and a Jean Jacket.
He's,
he was just so gay.
San Francisco,
Santa Monica in both Santa Monica.
This one,
the gas guy,
the only one that comes close to him.
I was in Houston once and I find I wanted,
want to congratulate this guy
the way he was rocking it,
but I didn't want to
offend them so I let it go.
But he had leg warmers on that.
We're rainbow that's already covered
leg warmers on and he had these little
designer,
like they looked like some odd tennis
shoe type thing that he was wearing,
some very trendy tennis shoe.
And then he had these boys gym shorts,
these board member,
those gym shorts he used to wear do
your blue with the white stripe and they
were way too small.
They were way too small.
Okay.
And he's our frail man as it is.
And then he had a pink skin,
tight shirt and a some
crazy multicolored Bandana.
And as he was working out,
he's working out like this,
like grunting
legwarmers man gas man that's
ever walked the face of the earth.
Absolutely.
This guy,
if he got together with the other guy,
they would create a black
hole of homosexuality.
It would eat its way through the cement,
eat cement,
spit,
come back at you.
It would be a sinkhole of gay.
If you slipped and fell into it,
you'd fall,
fall prey to the game.
You saw something.
Which one?
And lived in San Francisco.
He lives in San Francisco
at the college that she,
you definitely saw the gay thing
that you can see during the,
you said during the parade one time
you saw a guy is fucking on the corner.
Yeah,
on the street.
Just on the street.
I mean,
seen guys dress or a bed.
Do you see guys bud fucking on the street?
You'd be like straight up.
You'll never forget that
street at that moment.
It's one of the gas station.
Sure.
But I think it was during the
Folsom street fair and all in all,
so that,
that's like the gay
Mardi gras on the street.
I like to limit it to fairs.
Don't bring your kids if you're willing
to fuck on the street during the fair.
You're a real gangster.
Yes.
You're out there just fucking,
he's here.
You're a part of the problem.
Oh Hey,
we're at the,
the,
the bare Jim in our old neighborhood.
Yeah.
And some guys,
so this thing also in
bare culture is they,
these big guys,
they also like to build their Musk.
Yes.
And that's another part of it.
And Tommy,
one time I would think you
were downwind of a guy,
weren't you?
A fan was behind him or something.
Fuck man.
And you could smell it.
It was like,
it was so strong.
It wasn't like Jim Smell strong.
It was like a personal body odor that,
you know,
you can just tell when someone's Bi
was kicking butt kicking because he was
dirty.
Like cotton washed it.
Yeah.
It was,
it was a definitely a,
I haven't showered in like in a while.
Maybe it's to ward off the smell
of shit while you're fucking,
you ever think about that?
I,
I mean,
there's got to be such a pride.
He had such pride about his Musk.
I could just tell like
the way he was like,
right.
You picking up what I'm
putting out there right now?
Like look about them genre.
Yeah.
I imagine that some people were walking
through the gym that day like thanks
brother.
Thanks for putting this out here cause
you got me fired up to be ready to do
some squats.
I'm writing this motherfucker smells good.
Damn.
Yeah,
there's different levels
of like gay guys to write,
but what they're into like some guys would
just send to other like crazy big gay
guys and some guys they like twinks.
They like little tiny little boy.
Yeah.
There was this dude that
I shave it down brother,
but I knew that it was a
producer type character.
So wealthy character always had
like these young boys with them.
They were always like just 20 years old.
A little confused like that's I know
a well known comic or likes that one.
The only know why.
Yeah,
that's true.
I know several.
Yeah,
that's sort of a,
it's kind of a type.
There's all types.
There's Otters,
otters.
What's an honor?
No,
I believe in honor.
It's a tall,
slender.
Hairless is an auditor as
opposed to a big hairy fat,
which is a bear.
And a younger bear is actually a cub cub
bears go with cubs and cubs
are just smaller and more.
It was wrong.
But now I heard that the word Twinkies
becoming taboo to the way that bag is
kind of not cool to say.
I think twink is starting to become
what stopped,
you know,
well here's what happened.
So you know,
Andy Cohen on Bravo,
I think he went on some
other show and he's like,
oh look at all these twinks here.
And then the twin community got really
upset and started tweeting and so he
apologized.
But um,
everybody is just looking for
an opportunity to be sensitive.
We are in such a weird time is it's
like people have found reward in like
pointing at like hot button,
things like that.
Like,
Hey,
you know,
at the twin community we do not
organize.
You know,
who else
is fucking super annoying and like this,
I mean this one's way different level
of like how fucking what assholes they
are.
Is this like 1 million moms group?
It's just like we're mothers that are
Christian that want to raise the fucking
like great kids and like,
but we're complete politically bigoted,
uh,
discriminatory assholes.
They publicly lash out for the,
this is like the second or third time at
JC Penney for having Ellen to generous
after spokesman.
They're like,
you realize that none of us are ever going
to shop there again because you good.
You hired Ellen to be
like that kind of shit.
Like,
and they got really mad about her latest
Christmas commercial with Elvis and
they're like,
you have fucking a gay woman with Elvis.
What's going to fucking happen next?
Hey,
that's a good point.
Yeah.
I mean,
what,
what happened?
Eons mixing up with
magical creatures chick.
The crazy.
Definitely.
What if they like develop some
ways they have nefarious intention,
so they developed some sort of lesbian
pixie dust sprayed over a city when
they're flying around
and your kids because
yeah,
we've got a bunch of miniature
gay elves running around.
Listen man,
you mock
Ian Community.
Have these genres.
I don't know.
Yeah,
yeah.
They have lipstick.
Lesbian.
I'd have those Fred Flintstone.
Looking lesbian lipsticks the best,
right?
Yeah.
The lipsticks
100%.
Yet the other ones are intimidating,
especially if they want to fight,
but not always good at shows.
Either.
You'd want to argue over
the best instance of humor
can be cool.
They can be.
It's like you can't really generalize
a whole fucking sexual orientation.
I've met a lot of cool lesbians.
Annoying straight people too.
God Damn it.
That's true.
That's sort of the anti positive approach.
Everybody's got their own special gift.
Everybody sucks in their own
way to the dark play trail.
That's hilarious.
And so true.
It's true.
We have a little something,
a little something fucking with us.
I had to ask you this.
I haven't,
uh,
I wanted to get your thoughts on uh,
Pacquiao going down to
mark has this crazy crazy,
huh?
Yeah.
Well many pack y'all.
First of all,
it's a super nice guy.
Tosh and I film this thing
with him where I played,
uh,
Daniel Tosh is manager and uh,
he uh,
was to let Manny Pacquiao punch him in
the face of some strange reason like
that.
And so Manny Pacquiao,
he's very nice about it by the way.
He like,
like kind of tapped him and
then like hit him harder,
hit him harder and Taj is looking at
me like what the fuck man mean he's not
going to hurt you to little harder,
harder,
you know.
And,
and even then Manny Pacquiao
just sort of pop like so gently,
you know?
But he's so nice.
He's like a really friendly guy.
Like he doesn't have any
like weird feeling around
like he's a super duper star.
He travels deep with like this giant
entourage entourages taken care of
everything around him all the time and
he's like the nicest guy in the world.
So that made me sad.
But that's the game he's playing.
He plays a crazy game.
That game is you,
you are competing with your consciousness,
you're competing with
your physical health,
your competing against another
man who's a trained killer.
And when,
when he hits you,
you,
your body is just like any other body.
And if someone hits you
perfectly like he did twice,
he name dropped him with that first one
and mo most likely he was still hurt
from that.
But that's second punch was so powerful.
That was like the perfect punch cause
Pacquiao was moving forward and mark has
caught him moving forward and just crushed
him in his tracks and he was lights
out on the way down.
Yeah,
it was one of the worst or,
or best one punch knockouts
I've ever seen in all of boxing.
I think it goes in the top 10.
It's,
it's like,
I mean that,
that shit is right up there with uh,
Paul Williams getting knocked
out by Sergio Martinez.
Did you see that?
Sergio Martinez is,
it got a vicious lefthand and he's like
super athletic and moves around a lot
and he nailed Paul Williams like this
perfect overhand left as he was moving in
and just spun him around and face planted.
It was just like that.
He's at that,
but I just didn't expect to see that.
I think,
well,
you know,
I think I was seeing some stats on it
that that was his first time being knocked
out.
Yeah.
Since 19 well he hasn't been,
maybe not sound even [inaudible]
98 I think he's been dropped,
dropped.
I think it has been dropped.
Some incredible stat that like it hadn't
happened since 98 that he was thinking,
well actually now that I think about it,
I think mark has dropped him in his fight,
this fight before he knocked him out.
That was the first time mark
has it knocked him down.
He had knocked,
mark has done before,
but mark has had staggered him before,
but somebody had stopped
him earlier in his career.
He had,
he had been knocked out early in
his career but never liked this.
This was one of those knockouts
that might just be a game changer.
Yeah,
that's so really,
and you know boxers,
what you're seeing first of all in in
many is you're seeing a guy who's already
had before this fight,
they had three crazy fucking wars,
right?
Three wars back blasting
each other and you,
how many of those can you
have really in your life?
You know this,
there's a number,
it might be 10 it might be seven.
Everybody's different
depending on when you start,
depending on how good your defenses
you're going to get nailed.
You're getting your head hit,
you're getting your body,
you've got a lot of fun problems
that among other fights,
training,
sparring sessions just,
yeah,
Zach,
that was the point.
The point is what you're saying is a tiny
fraction of the actual damages head is
taken cause you're only seeing one fight
so you think about all the fights that
he's had to all the
punches that he's taken.
It's a tremendous amount
of punishment as is.
Then you have to factor in the fact
that that is a for action of the actual
punishment.
Then you start getting an idea of
what the fuck is really going on.
When you're training for a fight,
you have to have a number in your
head or a feeling or a time or what.
You got to know when to fucking get
out because the more you do that shit,
the more one day it's
going to catch up with you.
But with a guy like Pacquiao,
it's super hard for those
guys to just go out on top.
You know,
Floyd Mayweather retired
and then he came back,
he almost went out on top.
You almost said fuck it went out on top.
But I think he's probably the
most cautious of all of them.
Floyd.
Yeah.
He's the most cautious stylistically,
you know,
very rarely gets hit and he
does get hit recovers very well.
Like Shane Mosley was the last one to
tag him and he goes through entire fights
where he barely gets tagged.
Yeah,
yeah.
Just boxes the shit out of people,
you know?
And I love that.
I love the fact that the guy's still,
he's like,
not only is the unbeaten,
he's really unchallenged and he's like,
I think he's 36 now.
He's gotten pretty unheard of,
you know,
and it looks fantastic.
His defense is so incredible.
Brilliant boxer.
He's a brilliant,
and he probably would have box
the shit out of Manny Pacquiao,
especially seeing what he did,
the Martinez and what I
was able to do to Martinez.
And then what,
you know,
the differences,
uh,
Martinez in Floyd wasn't even close.
Floyd just outbox the shit out of him.
I mean he just couldn't get to him.
Floyd is just too good.
He's too good at positioning.
Amazing punches.
He recovers well and his,
uh,
people don't realize sometimes that like,
I mean depending on how good
whoever he's fighting at the time,
that a lot of times he boxes a
gloves down because he's so quick.
He doesn't even,
he doesn't pull up his
gloves for a lot of fights.
His gloves are down and
he's dipping around dance,
like playing with people.
Yeah.
Toy.
He does that shoulder roll.
Yeah.
Where he walks towards guys with his left
shoulder up high in his right glove by
his face and they don't know
what to do with that and fight.
He's,
he's so good.
It's pretty,
flexes are so good.
And,
and now that Adrian Broner Chi,
have you seen that kid?
But upcoming kid.
Oh my God,
this kid's a monster.
He's like Floyd Mayweather.
But with more punching power.
Same like weight class.
He's 47 I'm not sure.
Or it might be 35 is either
35 and struggling to make
the weight and moving up
to 40 or 47 whatever it is.
He's he's kids.
Dynamind he has that same style
that's high left shoulder up.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
There's some fucking shows up there.
No fucking lead glove for most of your,
like your left glove is down.
It's crazy.
It is crazy.
But the,
they're so good at those duck and roll
counter countywide hands and you don't
want to get clipped by that shit.
And then so like guys are real,
real cautious.
They don't know.
And he's so good at like slipping jabs.
So good at anticipating your movement.
The best boxers are great at leading
guys into certain directions and
anticipating how they respond.
You know?
And so like a guy like Floyd Mayweather
is not like an impulsive guy.
He's like a guy who's
going to set traps for you.
Right?
So like he'll lead you
in certain directions.
And see how you respond and then lead
you in that certain direction again and
see how you respond and then set you up
for a time where he's going to lead you
in that certain direction.
He's going to stop,
Bang,
he's going to catch you because you do
a certain thing over and over again.
You know you do a certain thing,
your gloves when you move off the ropes
and he's going to catch you figure it
out till he's got to figure
it out and that's like,
that's another thing
that Anderson Silva does.
Anderson Silva,
he moves around with the guy for like
the first minute or two kind of gets a
sense of how he,
how he operates,
how he moves faint some a little
bit and then start setting them up.
I started sending them out for,
for death,
for death.
Setting them up for a dismantling.
Yeah.
Floyd's even his defense is so interesting
and so developed it like when you
watch him box,
sometimes you'll see him get up
against the ropes and you're like,
oh he's,
he's up against the ropes.
This guy might take advantage of this.
And then Floyd somehow pulls it into his,
like his defense becomes
his offense and you're like,
oh no,
he's,
he's fucking ripping this
guy upon this too good.
He's so good at straight boxing.
I mean he's,
it's,
it's amazing.
And he's a guy that's had a lot of hand
problems too that kind of broke his
hands several times.
So he goes for like the biggest cushion.
He has gloves.
And because of that,
I think there's,
you know,
because of his fragile hands,
he'd probably,
there's a lot of guys who doesn't knock
out because of that very reason because
he's had like problems with
his hands over and over again.
But the way he knocked out,
um,
a homeboy from England,
the fuck's his name
hadn't Ricky Hatton Shit.
That was brilliant.
And that was what happened was in
his prime was on the animal floods.
So fast box the shit out of him.
He just boxes the shit out of guys.
They just can't get to them.
You just remind me,
I'm going to be in Vegas this week.
You'll Florida,
if you want to grab lunch.
If you want to grab dinner,
please bring Roger Lloyd leave
wants to be a part of team money.
Okay,
Tommy,
by the way,
man,
big fan,
Tommy buttoned that up
is all about team money.
Money team.
I want
to roll with you.
I need to know.
Watch dog.
What is going on,
man?
Tom Katt Williams hit somebody in the
head with a microphone or something and
then he punched the dude and
target and slap that guy.
Got in a car,
chase with the condo hour.
Give him a fucking break.
Jesus Christ so sensitive
to bring back to me.
We watched this 24 seven but
that his uncle Roger guys,
Black Mamba,
former champion himself,
black Roger May with the
head of vicious right hand.
Four,
seven.
Miguel Cotto is still my favorite,
right?
When was like,
I know Floyd is a supreme athlete.
Great boxer and a,
we have to be ready for war and
they cut to Roger Mayweather.
He goes,
fuck
about Miguel Cotto [inaudible] well,
the level
of technique that Floyd has is so
above and beyond everybody else.
He fights that.
He guys,
that kind of confidence
it made me Miguel Cotto,
especially during that
fight was a prime athlete.
Margarito was the only one that ever
really fucked up Miguel Cotto when he was
in his prime or that stomped him.
And that was when Margarita was accused
of having loaded gloves because he got
busted.
And Sherry did one of his,
uh,
subsequent fights.
But Miguel Cotto was a bad ass
fucking boxer boxing with Floyd.
It's like he just,
he makes everybody look goofy.
He makes everybody look,
they look like they just don't
really know what he's doing there.
Don't really belong in there with him.
He's,
he figured you out early enough
and now every time you step,
if popping a jab in your face
and there's no retaliation,
he's not there.
And then,
you know,
you look stupid and he's
slowly breaks you down.
He's just so good.
He's a,
he's superb,
superb boxer,
man.
It's Perv athlete.
But if I had a choice between
watching him and Anderson Silva,
I'd be like,
bitch,
I would way rather watch
Anderson Silva fight.
It's not even a question.
That's one of the reasons why
I like MMA so much better.
I like a good fight with Floyd Mayweather.
You know,
like if I found out for me
what was going to fight,
um,
packing out before this last thing,
then it would be super excited.
Sure.
Yeah,
that'd be he's,
he's fighting.
If he's fighting somebody
that I don't give a fuck.
Yeah.
It's like whatever.
He's just going to box this guy up.
It'll be interesting to watch know,
but I can watch on HBO next week.
Sure.
Yeah.
What,
how I've asked this before,
but how famous is
Anderson Silva in Brazil?
Oh,
it's like Michael Jordan and Michael
Jackson had a baby that it's incredible.
He's a super,
super superstar.
They love him.
Man.
That's awesome.
The cheers when he goes on
and on into the octagon,
when he steps up the
stairs and walks into the,
close the door behind them,
they're fucking definitely.
I took my headphones off and I said,
I go to Mike Goldberg while I
was talking to him on the ear.
I go,
take your headphones off.
I go take your headphones off and feel us.
He texts the headphones off.
He's like,
we're just looking at each other like,
Whoa,
there's 20,000 people in Rio and
they are going fucking bananas.
And Anderson walks in and bows and
they're going fucking ape shit.
That's so then he goes out there and this
man told Stephan Bonner in a way that
doesn't even seem human.
Yeah,
he,
he did it like some fucking Kung Fu
movie dude who just got bolted with some
secret lightening power.
He had a superpower so it
didn't even make any sense.
He did movie shit.
He stepped with his back up
against the cage and let Steph and,
or throw punches at him with his hands
down and just ducked and moved in front
of them and then through bond or the
ground and knock them unconscious with a
knee to the body,
blasted with a needle,
bonding this boom.
It goes down in a turtle position.
Done.
I mean he,
the way he did it was like,
it was,
it was superhuman.
It was like a guy in a movie.
Like,
if you saw a guy do that
and like Bourne identity,
black pitch,
nobody come on back then walk out of here,
put your back up against the wall.
Nobody puts their back
up against the cage.
Well,
how about the best fighter
in the fucking world?
Does that the best guy ever put his back
up against the case to a big giant dude
like Stephan Bonner and weight
down from like two 30 to fight it.
Two Oh five and Anderson fights at one 85.
He's still rag dolls the Chi.
Yeah,
it's freaky.
He's for Wiki.
There's nobody that freaks
me out when you watch them,
when you watch like the shit that they
can do to like really high level growing
fighters,
no one freaks me out.
Like Anderson Watching,
uh,
a rare master.
Like you're what?
You're like,
you're going to get a chance to
talk about this when you get old.
You know,
like there's people that will talk
about when they saw Joe Louis fight,
that's all well and good Anderson
Silva would've fucked up.
Joe Lewis.
Okay,
listen to me.
I don't care what anybody says.
Anderson Silva in an MMA
fight with fuck Joe Louis Up.
All right.
You're watching something crazy.
You're watching the baddest fighter
that's ever walked the face of the planet.
The shit he does.
The guys even like really good guys.
It's shocking.
Do you think he could beat
John Claude Van Damme?
It depends on which movie it is.
No.
If it's like one,
I'm John Claude van dams,
like one of his signature movies,
let's sport,
you know,
if it's like a blood sport to vandamme
has heart that will never be able to
appreciate it.
Have you ever seen him
cry and it's reality show.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
This
is awesome.
He's awesome.
He's awesome in a totally different way
than Steven Seagal is awesome as well.
But,
but John Claude van Damme was awesome
and a completely different way.
What was the cool,
the movie that he came
out a year or two ago,
what was the movie came out with?
It was like about,
what do you think?
I'm crazy.
You think I know what movies he's doing?
No,
no,
no.
This one was actually good
where he played JC Vd.
Yeah.
Made himself.
That was good that I'm blue ray
[inaudible] I never said I wasn't a fan.
I love John Claude van Damme,
but he's still crazy and he has
a reality show and he plays,
I guess I've only seen the videos,
the internet,
but you could readily
get them on the Internet,
but it's wonderful.
Okay.
He's crazy.
Yeah.
Okay.
And he keeps talking about,
I'm going to hit this fight.
I'm going to have to fight one
more time for the children.
Like he has like crazy ideas.
I did,
you know,
they said,
John,
you did a lot of cocaine and you know,
you know a lot of other things.
I'm not happy about those other things,
but I'm going to make it up with this
fight and I'm going to win but not ouch.
And it's like so crazy and
over the like he's acting,
it's like this strange hybrid
between a reality show and a movie.
And what he's doing is really strange
because he's saying he's going to have a
fight and he's got this guy that he keeps
dragging around with them that these
things happen.
But the promise has been doing
this for like four years.
So this guy for these four years,
he's been saying he's going to fight like,
and they pose for stare
downs for me years,
years man.
I mean for fucking this weird,
it's still going on and he's still like,
well,
you know,
I'm going to have this fight and I'm
going to do it for the children to show
them you can bounce back from out of this
bullshit and this cocaine and fucking
wonderful.
Can we do that?
Uh,
that might be it.
That might be one of them.
I mean there's a lot of them.
He's got a lot of them.
Can I do,
he seems like a really nice guy.
It seems like real friendly and you know,
he doesn't seem like he's
trying to be a hard ass.
Like even when he sang like
he's going to knock it out.
You're like,
oh,
come on,
give me a hug.
Come on.
Get over here and give by the way,
cocaine man,
you know that you said the a,
it's like a weird hybrid between like
reality and like I think that's the,
that's the new and next steps that's
going to really develop for television is
like shows like a duck hunters.
The Duck Dynasty Duck Dynasty where
it's that family and they go this is the
reality show.
But it's clearly like it's produced
to well you're like there's no way.
Like these are real people.
They're not,
you know,
they're not actors but like
all the moments are to well
construct like the wife
comes in right at the moment when the
guys are like fucking cutting a hole in
the ceiling and she was like Texas.
It's in Louisiana.
Yeah.
Louisiana.
You done lost your redneck.
Oh Man.
You don't love.
Yeah.
It's a funny show.
Show you.
I lost my redneck.
These
girls frog legs.
I love that old guy.
The patriarchs.
Great in that.
It's,
sorry I'm full of shit though.
It's full of Shit.
Have you seen swamp people?
No.
Swamp people is just,
they should call that
show alligator assassins.
Okay.
Cause it's just a bunch of motherfuckers
that live in Florida and kill
alligators and they kill
off fuck load of alligators.
Okay.
They killed like 500 of them a season.
I went to high school
with a few of those guys.
I think I remember them.
Do they kill a lot of alligators?
It's really to think there's that
many God damn alligator's out there
and you know it's really freaky.
A lot of people might not like this,
but if they weren't
killing those alligators,
those alligators would fuck
and make more alligators.
And if you think of how many
fucking alligators they're killing,
do you know what kind of an infestation
of alligators we must have in this
country?
Jesus Christ.
If they're killing hundreds and
hundreds of them and in Florida,
Holy Shit,
they have to still in the order
when the back yards all the time,
man,
all the time.
When I lived in Gainesville,
they were protected.
You couldn't kill them.
Really?
Yeah.
When I was a kid,
I lived in Florida and you know that.
Yeah.
I lived in Gainesville for two years.
My Dad was going to the
University of Florida and um,
we,
uh,
we used to go to Lake Alice.
There's this like little lake there
and we used to feed the alligators
marshmallows.
Yeah.
You'd flip throw marshmallows,
the water.
You'd be like,
wow,
these are crazy monsters
are feeding these monsters.
But they didn't really
fuck with people too much.
They occasionally would like get a dog.
Like if someone would,
they walk their dog
too close to the water,
didn't see the alligator.
Alligator can't help themselves,
but I guess they would
feed them or something.
I Dunno.
I don't know what the fuck they did.
They must have done something to keep
them happy if they are around people.
But apparently it got to a certain point
where they were just so many fucking
alligators.
They had to do something.
Oh yeah.
Every,
I mean I used to see,
I went to high school
in Florida and you know,
you would see them all the courses.
You see people's backyards there.
Let people have pools and
Florida and up till people,
alligators.
I don't think it happens that often.
I don't think it happens that often,
but I mean I'm sure it has.
I mean,
I'm sure there's statistics on it,
but I don't remember a lot
of one a year maybe sandy,
one of those kinds of things.
Yeah,
I know people lose,
you know,
limbs and shit.
People go to get their golf ball
and they go into a little pond.
You can lose a hand.
Fuck,
fuck you let that ball go.
What you do man?
Fuck,
fuck,
fuck.
Get a new title list.
She's,
we'll leave it in the water.
Absolutely horrifying.
Like human flesh.
That's not their first crack at it.
Like
he'll eat a bag of shit.
They will.
They would eat people.
They just haven't been to
plates and tires and the shit.
It's not their preference one way
or on road rules in Australia.
We went to a crocodile farm and like
the guy that owned it was explaining how
they don't really want to eat us,
but if they're hungry
and there's nothing else,
that's when they'll fuck with you.
If you're down by the fucking
swamp and you're like,
Oh hey,
what are you doing here?
And then it'll grab you in depth
roll you.
But I think that the only reason why
they don't do is because they don't
recognize us as a food source.
It's delicious meal because
they don't usually eat us.
But once they recognize
us as a food source,
that's when it becomes a real problem.
Like there was one they
killed in the field,
the Philippines recently,
and it was fucking huge,
huge saltwater crocodile and they,
it had killed a bunch of villagers.
Like they didn't,
they knew that there was
this one giant crocodile,
it was more than 20 fucking feet long
and it was killing people and they'd,
so they had to go after it and go get it.
There was,
and there was that one that was like,
it wasn't in Canada one that the
movie is based on like they made up.
Yeah.
W Crocodile and Canada.
I know some
lake,
it was like a norm.
Some of northern sitting
leg was about not a Croc,
maybe,
maybe a gator.
Right.
That's what the movie's about.
It's like a horror movie.
It's not Lake Michigan.
Remember the movie like Michigan?
Pat Plath?
Was it placid that about the movie?
That's based on a real story.
I swear to God,
I met one of the,
I think I met one of the writers
on that who told me that.
Yeah,
I'm pretty sure man,
like based on,
I might be wrong on the location,
but I know it's based on
a real murdering gator.
I think so is that right?
What's the true story of
Lake placid is alligator.
Let's go to Wiki answers.
How beautiful is this day then?
It's in a just do that.
And I know you used to have
encyclopedia Britannica.
That shit was wack as fuck the
stories based off the 1943 mysterious
disappearances of 10 teenagers while
playing one night on lake placid.
Okay.
So,
uh,
it's just uh,
okay.
Just a rumor.
But the mood,
what?
So the movie,
just the movie the gate or
concept to it or something?
Well,
apparently it became a legend because
it happened in 1943 and so people would
talk about it.
And so the movie is like based on this
actual monster and it's sort of a,
it's a factual short,
don't send me your tweets or
your emails about how I'm wrong.
I'm right.
We just read it on the Internet.
Basically.
It's in what you said cannot be argued.
There you go.
Yeah.
What does a dumb ass
movie fucking alligator,
but I'll get it would
be freezing as deck off
is it weighs 30 foot long man.
Eating crock it off.
Which terrorizes the fictitional
fictitional location of Black Lake Maine.
Oh,
that's even more ridiculous.
Maine's only like thought
out for like a month,
a year.
So I wasn't that far off when I,
when I said rate's pretty close.
That's close to Maine.
Sure.
There you go.
You were in that story.
Yeah.
Let me go write it down.
That's a winter gators.
If you think about like,
like a perfect nightmare
that's chasing after you,
it's a giant reptile,
right?
Because there's so emotionless
and conti and just,
they don't,
they don't give a fuck.
That's a dinosaur.
Yeah.
It's like a,
it's just an extension of,
uh,
the like a t rex chasing you.
It's an animal that has virtually
not changed for 200 million years.
They existed in this form
200 million years ago.
What the fuck,
man?
They're all muscle muscle in the,
they're just like the,
the cleaning systems of ecosystems.
They're like the cleaners.
They come in and anything that's limping,
you'd done.
Song
goes and tries to get water
out of the wrong spot.
Slam,
keep the population down.
Boom.
We're trying to cross this river and not,
yeah.
You ever see those river crossings
for those ones in io crocodiles?
Yeah.
Step up and just huge dinosaur jaws
clamped down on Willdabeast and drag them
underwater.
You're like,
well,
what is the going on here?
I always fix a system that's
set up totally a life system.
Life and death.
There is a population
control mechanism in effect,
big cats and alligators.
Does it,
I mean,
crocodiles,
is it any coincidence that's the
place where this is the most gazelles?
Oh yeah.
Fucking things are
running around everywhere.
Everything's running around everywhere.
Willdabeast and all these things.
You just giant things trying to eat
and we keep their populations down.
The thing at the footage,
the footage of that is always the same.
If you watch those,
those uh,
like a nat Geo shows,
they'll be like these 50 gazelles
crossing the river and you're like,
yeah.
And then like three seconds
go by and you're like,
oh,
there's one that's not with the pack.
I think we should watch him for a second.
And then you watch him kind of limping,
tentatively crossed the creek and that
crop comes up is like fucking over it.
There's such machines,
they're so terrified and they can
be under that water for hours.
They don't have to breathe for hours.
So they sit under the water waiting for
someone to come by and then the bars all
fucking murky and shit.
You can't see that big dinosaur
waiting there to eat babies.
Oh Man.
That monster.
And how perfectly designed as
where when you see you terrifying
footage of his eyes just out of the water.
So it's just up like just the water.
Horrific,
horrific monster.
I remember,
okay,
this is gonna Sound really lame,
but unreal.
Sros,
I had to,
um,
we had to put a bag
over a crocodile's head.
Oh my God.
So you have to,
at first you have to clamp,
it's Josh shut and then duct tape it and
then you put a bag on his head and then
you step you,
you sit on it,
you have to sit on it to hold it still.
And that's how we would transport it.
Like for one of the mission I was,
so this guy,
key flaw on the show,
you had a pole and he was trying to rope
the crocodiles neck and the crocodile
went into a death roll.
Oh Geez.
And his shirt got caught in the poll twist
around his arm and it was cutting off
the circulation and everybody was like,
oh fuck.
Like when that really
happens on a reality show,
like you don't know what to do.
So he was just screaming,
cut the shirt,
got the shirt,
got that fuck.
And I'm like,
we don't,
there's no scissors in the outback.
Like somebody had to rummage
through their sound kit or whatever.
And we were standing still spinning.
Spinning is when it ended up
a big as a solopreneur I was,
it was medium size,
10 to 15 feet long.
Teenager,
it was its teeth clamped down on a shirt.
Yeah.
So you clamp the jaw shut
and then somebody duct tapes,
the jaws together,
he got a hold of the teeth.
So no,
so,
so the next part is you have to
just put something around its neck.
So Keith Lowe was using a poll
with the rope at the end of it,
like a loop road.
So they loop it that,
right,
right.
So he did it in,
somehow this crocodile like got
latched onto maybe in this job,
the rope,
the,
and he just started
death rolling.
Oh Wow.
It got the polo shirt on his
sleeve and then tighten the sleeve.
So we had to cut the shirt off of him.
Got To wear spandex.
When you fucking with Crocker,
very important.
It'd be all tucked up,
tucked up and ready to sprint
cleats as well.
You don't want to be slipping.
Jesus Christ dangerous.
They found Nile crocodiles in Florida.
You heard that they have a shoot to kill
order on Nile crocodiles in Florida if
they spotted a couple of them so
people transport it in Nile crying.
Jesus fucking assholes.
That was probably some dude who's
trying to guard his cocaine.
I know what I'm gonna do.
Mine.
I'm going to have any fucking
more with [inaudible].
It was 28 foot long.
Edo either motherfucker,
Joe gonna fuck some Colombian.
Definitely.
Well didn't those dudes back in like the
Miami vice days didn't like those dudes
like kind of like,
like leopards in their backyard.
Yeah,
those guys.
[inaudible] alligator,
some,
some sort of a that's right.
It was chained up on his boat.
That's what I'm talking about.
During that dude,
that was the Douchey
era in all of humanity.
He's the eighties cocaine
days of Miami's Douchey.
His era of all time,
everybody wanted to have a pet tiger.
He'd go over to this guy's house.
He's got fucking peacocks
walking on his front lawn.
What's happening here and then,
you know,
all my shit is my python collection.
What we do is we grow them
to about 10 feet long.
I just take him by the everglades mean
you can't control him after eight 10 feet
long but I just get a
new one and you know,
start from scratch,
retrained
pythons that he fucking of pythons
out there long and same dude who has
grit and aids and I got a hundred
grenades and the living rooms.
I got rocket launches on the Mac
couch but I don't tend to use it.
Why do you have it if you
want to blow through a wall,
you know there's a wall in your way.
That's why I got to Puma.
My weight room,
I've got a Puma that I keep there for
inspiration sometimes I don't think him,
he'd get real hungry.
I'd be lifting weights right next.
I got some wolf color.
It's just the fact that he eyeballing
me knowing that I look delicious and
nutritious and he's starving to death
and they made me do more squats.
I can't make me
walkup paper plates with
diamonds on them and shit.
That shit.
In New York City,
I saw a reality show or someone they would
buy like baby crocodiles and shit and
keep them in the bathtub.
Yeah,
well people do that.
There was a guy who got a cool guy,
I think it was,
it was either Brooklyn or the Bronx,
but he got mauled by a tiger that
he had as a pet in and apart.
Oh,
you do?
Well,
I don't want to give up your bed.
No ma'am.
No,
it's just funny.
I the old one.
It's an old joke that,
not that I mean hit it buddy.
No,
I'll do it if you tell me the way
I talk about another guy.
I uh,
I talked about the guy,
um,
what's it called?
Um,
uh,
that had the animals at his
house and he released them,
you know,
Remember Ohio?
Yeah,
I have a bit about that.
That's on my plug plugging it or anything.
But yeah,
he did.
He Ke,
he killed him.
Well,
he cut up,
he released them all right.
And then I believe he cut up like some
chickens and like poured the blood all
over himself and with dead animals on him.
Right.
And then like,
you know,
he had lions and shit and he released.
So he got,
he got fucked up by everything.
I think he might've been
dead before they got to him,
but they eventually like animals
a pull in his dead body apart.
Oh,
easy way to go.
I've never heard that before.
Oh,
that's a,
that's a dude who really loves animals.
Yeah.
Right.
Our system was silly.
Fuck yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
you know the,
the whole
zoo life is really a,
it's a,
it's a crazy torture that we do so that
we can look at animals in real life
because they don't even allow them to
live a natural life while in captivity.
It's one thing if we had them in an
ecosystem that was similar to their own,
so we put them in these containment areas,
then we let loose antelope.
So whatever the fuck it is that they
get to run and chase down and kill
[inaudible] that was the case.
I think that that would at least be
like rewarding life and these cats,
when you keep pushing that meat out to
them and they don't get any sort of chase
reward thing going on,
we see like the play with each other.
Like they want to chase things like it's
a part of the whole dynamics of their
organism,
like their design to chase and kill Shit.
They're designed to kill all the shit and
so you put them in this cage just like
jolting their brain like they never get
a chance to express what they were put
on earth to do.
It sounds fucked up but it's depressing
but you mean what are you going to do?
You're going to stop the gazelles from
breeding and you're going to control the
gazelle,
but I can put,
put a few fucking gazelles
in the cage with them.
Okay.
Just let them know
we don't need to watch it.
I'll pay extra.
Here's the team.
What's the difference?
God it between the meat that you're giving
them because you're giving them meet
you.
Someone's killing an animal and
someone's giving him that mean.
Why can't he do that?
Because you know he wants to,
yeah,
well someone else is killing it.
It's not like you're saving an animal,
someone else's killing a fucking
animal and you're cutting.
Yeah.
I mean you're sliding under the track.
Why not just let a cow loose and let
them that don't go out and talk about
driving revenue like,
because they're like,
hey,
it's an extra 70 to watch.
Here you go.
You know,
that's what they do in Asia,
in Asia and they feed tigers.
They released goats.
Brian,
Paul pornos videos up.
You ready to freak the fuck out?
Yes.
This is like a common thing
theme.
Apparently in Asia they,
they,
when they have tigers,
they just have this big dump truck and
they have the dump truck with a couple of
fucking goats in it and yeah.
And the goat doesn't know
what the fuck is going on.
But the,
do
you know why?
Because a new goat gets dropped
off like that every day.
Yeah.
So the Tigers like stand there and stare
while this thing backs up and beeps and
they just wait and they
get real close to it.
And as soon as this thing opens,
the goat dumps out and boom,
they jump on a three,
four minute time,
rip it apart into shreds in a matter
of seconds and they run away with like,
one's got head,
one's got a leg.
I love this.
You find any,
that's what they're supposed to do.
Wait,
do you see this shit?
Because this is a weird thing to see,
but this is what they want to do.
Okay.
I mean if you're going to kill that,
go to anyway.
If you're going to feed him,
go.
Why?
Why we need to do that.
Because then at least,
I mean it's still fucked
up that you're got them.
You've got them contained like that,
but it leaves.
Then they get to live a tiger's life.
I feel like the only reason we don't get
that it's because of like some type of
animal rights organizations here that
don't really exist in other parts of the
world about what I'm saying.
I think our own lives for a lot of
people are so fucking suppressive and
ridiculous and restrained that we don't
give a fuck about that stupid elephant.
Tough Shit,
bitch.
Yeah.
Take your cage.
I don't like my cubicle.
Right.
Here's one.
Look at this.
Alright.
They just sitting there
watching and waiting.
These are lions.
This is a different lab,
but a they do.
Yes.
They do.
It lives too,
so they just sit around and
they lift up this dump truck.
They're opening the door right
now and the lines are just,
they're just hovering
right in front of it.
Erica,
this guy's talking is that beep?
Is this Guy Hockey?
His Horn?
He's trying to control the
lines by honking his horn.
It hasn't.
If we're in this and you're hogtied,
this horn ain't doing shit to
these lines because they know.
Here it comes.
Yup.
Now the guy's going to lift it up.
It's really going high now and
the things going to drop out.
Why is he haunting with the horns?
Some of the best.
Maybe he's got his dick out.
Hey,
we'll do it here.
He pulled it out of it.
There it is.
Oh my God.
That's it.
They just latch onto it.
I guess.
Toy Rip it to shreds.
Yep.
Look at it.
They're all playing tug of war.
There's like nine lines and then another
one tries to get in this one pot at him
seeing that one's pawn at them.
I don't hear it.
I don't hear her crying anymore.
What happened?
She's like guys,
no.
I think,
look at that.
God dammit.
Oh,
people are screaming.
That is awesome.
I pay a lot to see that
a seven year old.
Okay.
You do not want to fuck that shit
girl or a boy if that's a girl.
You do not want to fire ground.
If that's a boy,
he needs to be monitored.
It needs to be monitored.
Like that piece that Josh,
Oh these are,
these are impressive,
but these are lions.
If you could find tigers,
Brian,
see if we can find tigers.
Cause the tiger video that
I saw is way more quick,
way more quicker,
were a kid was spying on
the Roche's see more humane.
Oddly,
when you're feeding these wild animals,
it's totally more than to
be in their element to be,
that's your nature.
That's what they're supposed to be.
No,
we've,
we've already,
I think that weighs ridiculous
where the slow dump truck,
but there should be a gate and you
should let a couple of them out in the
morning.
Yeah.
What are the fucking,
I think the footage I saw what time
was from the Baghdad zoo was like that
terrible way to die.
Someone's honking their horns and all
sudden they're playing tug of war with
your body.
Just ripping parts of your
body with these monsters,
jaws and teeth that penetrate flash had
just pulling you apart literally for
your,
for your sustenance,
for your flesh.
What else?
Suck world.
The world of the jungle
is like God the world.
The jungle was a
motherfucker is another one.
This guy's had this again,
same st
ty would Saiger look how much
bigger the Tigers lions again,
a motherfucker would a horn.
This is like sport for them,
I guess.
They don't want to climb inside.
There it is.
Check this out.
It's like,
Hey,
look at this.
Boom.
Oh my God,
listen to that thing that
he's decided he's,
he's killing it now,
so he's just getting a
how the neck look at that.
That's it.
He broke the neck and killed it.
Look how quick he killed that thing,
man.
That's a cow.
He killed no,
that cow.
Like instantly use jaws.
He just took it,
snapped it and killed it.
It didn't look like it
took a lot of effort,
was kind of looked like he was paying
up a cup to have a sip out of it.
That was a cow.
And I've seen him like the goat ones,
the most fucked up one because they
just tear them apart and run away with
pieces.
Ooh,
wow.
Way to go for that goat.
But if you're a goat,
you gotta realize like this
is what you're here for.
You're here to eat
grass and get fucked up.
The food chain.
One of these days,
someone's going to find you slipping
and they're going to eat your ass.
Yeah.
And you guys walk and make a lot of noise.
Mountain lions have eight years.
Just going to slowly sneak up behind
you bitches and someone's going to get
jacked.
Damn,
that's,
you live in the 10 pretty small.
You got to get out of here.
No.
I said,
I can't believe how little effort
that was so easy to kill a cow,
a cow,
cow grabbing by the next shook it snapped.
Boom.
Be taken down by a lion or a crocodile.
I think you want a lion because
lions going to actually kill you.
Yeah.
The crocodile just start eating
you and they drown you too.
They would drown you.
I mean,
they'll,
they'll eat first.
They don't.
That's what the Deli,
that death row,
those crocodiles love,
they'll eat your fucking delicious dick.
I think that's the thing with bears too,
is a bears.
They don't,
they don't kill you first.
They just eat you.
Because if you,
what you want to do is you want to get
killed by a Predator because predators
are always,
if you're getting killed by something
that doesn't always kill it stuff.
Sometimes he eats a lot of things
that it finds laying around,
whether it's in or whether it's,
um,
a berries or vegetables like bears.
They fight just,
they just eat you.
They didn't know that I can certainly
killing you once they have you.
They have you say they
wait 1200 fucking pounds,
so they just start eating.
Why kill you first?
So carefree,
scream,
good.
I'm trying to eat your Dick.
They just just shoo chunks of you.
They say that the Grizzly man
documentary when that guy,
yeah.
Amazing.
Right folks,
if you have not watched grizzly man,
it's one of the best unintentional
comedies in the history of film.
Yeah.
It's kind of our love story.
When we were dating I was like,
I don't know,
I forget,
but we were like,
we got to go see this movie.
But this fucking guy
that lived with bears,
I remember that.
I remember the news story breaking and
that we went and we're sitting in this
theater,
I think it was in Pasadena at a Lemley,
so it was more of like it was playing
in like the art artsy theater.
It wasn't in like the
major release theaters.
It was in the artsy theaters around
and we went and there was like,
I don't know,
maybe like 50 or 60 people at it and
the whole time every like basically beat
over the movie were in hysterics laughing.
And the other 50 people are not like,
they're all serious movie
goers that like really feel
for like
two years
we're getting looks from people that
were getting looks like it's not fucking
funny.
He's dead.
Oh,
that's what,
funny though.
It's like it does a disservice to
his life to pretend he wasn't funny.
Remember the pilot,
the best lines that the pilot who,
uh,
would drop them off and he was like,
and he decided he wanted to
go live with bears in the,
yeah,
I thought it was retarded.
[inaudible]
my favorite part was when
he was walking around with his camera,
talking to his camera about how
easy it would be if he was gay,
but he's not gay.
He's like,
so obviously gang walking around with
his camera and he's like talking to it.
I ran into some guy who,
um,
his roommate,
like apparently the grizzly man was
in love with his roommate and when his
roommate didn't reciprocate,
he trashed his apartment.
Apparently he was a
bit of an angry fellow.
Like if you ever saw the video and he's
screaming and yelling into the camera,
he does like a bunch of different takes
pairs.
I worked it out
and he's got this like really
obvious like sort of fam gay voice.
He's got that voice like this
undeniable stereotypical
like cartoonish gay boys.
Yeah,
it does.
And so he's walking,
holding up the camera going,
well,
if I was gay I could just go to a rest,
stop and meet a guy bought,
I'm not,
he Treadwell's not gay.
And it's like the weirdest thing.
Like this poor fucking guy.
Like he was so torn up and confused and
conflicted that he just decided to go
live with bears.
He missed,
he misread the fucking newsletter
and when after real bears.
Yeah,
guys like me.
[inaudible]
it was crazy how close
he got to the animals.
They're like with a fox
became his little buddy.
Oh,
he's like touching her shit.
Wasn't the Fox called
like Foxy Fox is foxy?
What was the thing?
Chocolat it also says us so gay.
When he got,
remember when the bear approached him
one time bear was approaching him and he
was like,
he was like,
fuck you.
Fuck you.
Or like you're waiting for me.
I love you.
Oh,
that's what it was.
The reverse.
He has to be in IBM.
Let's stern with them.
Have to be stern with them.
No,
don't want to let him get in too close.
Apparently the death video where they
never got a kit lens on it so it's only
audio.
The other cap on but the camera
was running is seven minutes long.
It took them seven minutes
for the bear to eat them.
It was him and his girlfriend.
The barrel of the bolts.
The girlfriend hit the bear over the head
with a frying pan apparently a couple
of times in the barrels like
bitch and there was a sick bear.
Apparently it was sick bear.
They found out like later on.
I remember you could look it up that I
don't remember if the bear had like some
type of disease.
I don't know,
the rabies or something
where it was not in a,
it wasn't like a healthy normal
functioning bear is what that was.
But it was,
I didn't know it was something else.
I,
that's what I read is that they didn't
really find much of the bear because the,
they shot the bear when they,
uh,
they flew over and they
saw that the bear had,
uh,
had,
had killed these people because apparently
a pilot saw the rib cage coming up.
That's what he saw.
And he realized that this
bears eating a person.
He saw close saw tent all the camp.
So he knew that the bear
was eating a person.
So the,
um,
they got a guy,
you know,
one of the ranges I guess shot him.
And then when they went back,
I think it was like a
couple of months later,
there was nothing left.
It was like,
you know,
there was just a fucking a
couple pieces of bones I thought.
I thought they found
the diamond is the guy.
I don't know.
They might have,
I mean they might have processed
the bears guts once they're,
yeah,
they killed him as well.
Likely.
And by no means,
you know,
if you're listening,
do not let this deter you
from living with them.
Fine
dictated to all these Alaska shows,
man.
Oh,
it's really cool.
I watch all these last
frontier shows like Alaska,
the last and the Yukon
man and that is courageous.
He live in man and he just went hunting
somewhere up north than you Montana.
But that's Marty
Montana doesn't give a fuck.
Okay.
That place is,
we went down the Missouri River and to
a place called the bad lands and the
badlands does not give a fuck.
You might as well have gone to the moon.
Really?
Yeah.
You might as well be on the moon.
There's no one there.
There's no cell phone signal
and you ain't got shit.
You got no radio and you are in what
is the bottom of a giant ancient ocean?
He used to be the great western
inland sea during the Jurassic period,
like there was dinosaurs and
Shit Roman through that area.
So the bottom,
the ground everywhere is like silt.
It's like that same like slippery
shit on the bottom of the lake.
So you have mountains sort of
covered in silt and theirs.
They had homesteads out there
where they gave people like you,
you,
if you live there,
you could claim a giant chunk of land
and as long as you lived on it for a
certain amount of time,
it would be your land.
Well,
they gave these people
land and they all left.
They all quit.
No one can,
you can't grow anything on it.
Yeah.
It's like this crazy silty shit.
And there's,
I mean there's deer round,
but man,
you've got to fucking hunt for
days sometimes to kill one.
Wow.
So you're out there camping and trying
to catch these deer and bringing them
back to your family at
a certain point in time.
Like,
look,
we've got to get the fuck out of here
and we're going to run out of food.
And so they all did.
They all bailed.
They,
these,
this just not reliable.
And in the wintertime it
gets way too fucking cold.
It gets so cold at the river.
Freezes the river fees a solid.
Yeah,
you got to cut holes in it and
try to get fish out of there.
Bitch.
Good luck trying to
feed yourself like that.
So they all bailed.
Wow.
So that's why we,
we went hunting.
It was fast.
That's pretty awesome.
It's like,
it was literally like
going to another planet.
It was so humbling,
you know,
the live outside like that for five days
and that kind of environment is really,
really,
really humbling because you,
you start to feel it,
you start to see like how Frat,
first of all,
how fragile you are.
Even just the temperature,
like it was 12 degrees out.
When we're sleeping outside,
it's 12 degrees.
So you're bundled up in this sleeping
bag and shit and zipped over your head
and,
and we're trying to
squeeze yourself to Ge,
so make your body warm and it's 12 degrees
and nothing gives a fuck about you.
And it's just a bunch of things
out there eating other things.
That's all it is.
It's deer eating grass.
Mountain lions eaten deer.
We found mountain mine shit is big
thick rope of shit with fur in it.
It's like,
whoa son.
No,
you see him,
you know this is the food chain.
This is this one.
Really harsh ecosystem.
Yeah.
Not Survive or guy or he goes out,
he went to like Scotland.
Yeah,
and just on the other side of the hill,
if there's people living right at the
Morris or whatever on the other side,
he tries to spend the night.
There were people do live
just out in the wild and he,
you know,
we almost spreads his dick off.
It's fucking cold.
It's an uninsured.
Is this the real survivor
man or that other guy?
I remember which one is that guy?
That guy who slept in hotels.
There was a guy slept in hotels
that made it seem like he wasn't.
Yeah,
you didn't know that.
No.
First of all,
the real guys,
Les Stroud,
less trout is the real guy.
He goes out even for,
he goes for 10 days now
films it all himself.
He's,
he's the real deal.
He's legit.
But that bear Grylls character,
that dude is apparently in
the some like military guy.
He probably is like sort
of a survival expert.
But when he was doing that show,
he was like faking a lot of shit.
Like we just came upon a seal caucus.
Now we can use this for food.
Yeah,
that guy,
he's like,
he didn't really come
across the seal carcass.
Like they put that thing there and they,
according to les,
Les says they made man vs wild because
they were always trying to get him to
fake shit,
but he wouldn't fake shit.
We had him on the podcast
he was talking about.
He's like,
I wouldn't say wow.
Yeah,
so the,
that's,
he told me that that's what they
got bear Grylls to do his show.
They were like,
we'll show you.
We're going to do the same show,
do your own show,
but we're faking everything.
But meanwhile everybody found out they
fake things and nobody wants to watch it
now.
Horse.
Oh,
watch some dude.
Pretend any sleep in the
jungle or helicoptered into
a four star hotel and the
disco at night drinking Margaritas and
put it back there in the morning and he's
like,
oh,
what a night fi's get his feet massaged.
Well deal at night in a
jungle is not pleasant,
but thankfully I can trick
my own UPIs to stay hydrated.
Don't drink ocean water
but drink plenty of urine.
Love that shit though.
I love all that stuff.
I love the real shit.
I don't love,
I can't watch the bear Grylls show
as soon as I found out that they were
manufacturing scenarios and no,
he's just showing you.
I understand what they're saying.
They're saying he's showing you how you
would survive if you came across this so
let's just make this happen
and have him deal with it.
But he did a lot of shit that was like
you would never do like really dangerous
risky shit.
Like jumping off of things.
Like why is he jumping off of this
sliding down the sides of mountains,
like why are you doing why
you're doing it like this.
This isn't like seems dangerous.
Go sliding into an ice cave like why?
What's,
there's nothing in there for you.
Don't go in that Nice caring,
preserving.
That's Christ.
What are you doing there?
Avoid that cave.
Just a crazy asshole.
I totally,
but that's what they want you to do.
If you tried to like
make a atomic Christina,
your mom's house reality show,
do you know how much fucking
bullshit you'd have to deal with it?
What?
Oh,
for sure.
First of all,
because you guys don't have a
big enough name to carry it,
just based on that,
they're going to have to promote it,
so they're going to have to say,
well,
you know Tom,
look,
I know you're a well known standup
comedian in the world of standup comedy,
but people don't know you as an actor.
Okay,
so we're going to need
some help with this.
You need to help us along with this.
We're going to,
we're going to get to get your show going.
It's,
it's not all reality.
Okay?
What is reality?
Okay,
this is it.
We're going to make some things
happen and you just do your thing.
When the thing is really happening,
we're just making it
happen and we're like,
oh yeah,
okay,
sure.
So next thing you know you guys were in
marriage counseling and have it a fake
argument.
You know Walrus in the backyard and
you lost your redneck.
Well I'd love to make that
show if you're proposing.
No telling you don't do it and
try and tell you that I'm selling,
I'm selling.
If you're buying and selling,
well that's the thing about you guys,
this podcast,
your podcast is a perfect because
nobody tells you what to do.
Like all podcasts,
they really,
they represent it.
Really represent what
the fuck you're thinking.
Yeah,
totally.
You don't,
you don't lose the message
and the producers or you know,
network notes or any,
any of that shit.
Yeah.
It's what it's what,
it's really what you want it to be
and that's what's cool about like the
different circle of podcasts.
Like,
especially like ones that feel like are,
you know,
they run off from like people that you're
associated with is that it's each is
like a representation of each of
everybody's personality and who they are.
Like,
you know,
skeptic tank with Ari is,
it's so you're getting that's who already
is and that's what he wants to show to
be.
And you know,
uh,
Joey Diaz is the same way.
It's and then what's happening now.
Absolutely.
And then I just did Duncan
Trussell family hour.
So Dunkin is that,
that's a total Dunkin experience
and you're getting to know the guy.
And then Burt just came
out with a podcast.
Burt cast,
I did the first episode I should say.
I just sat there and laughed on the
first episode because it was in Burt's at
first place.
He had Joey Diaz and his
father and me in this room.
And Bert is,
is,
you know,
he's steering the ship.
It's what he wants it to be.
That same thing.
But you just sit there listening to Diaz.
Mr Kreischer,
the fucking funniest thing of,
I mean,
I was crying.
I was at,
I was in tears.
It was so funny.
And um,
what we do in your mom's house,
it's totally,
it's exactly what we want the show.
To me that's the most fun
about it.
Is it totally what you want it to be?
We're so lucky right now.
Right.
Did judge,
you was like feel that I feel so fortunate
to be a standup comic because you
don't need the big networks now.
If you want to do your fucking hour,
you don't need to go
through comedy central.
If you want to talk to your audience,
you can reach them directly
through the podcast.
They can download at any
time of day or night.
It's the best thing.
And what's really cool about this is that
people that get into a position where
people are paying attention to,
then they can tell you
about some other cool shit.
Right?
Sort of like retweeting.
Yeah,
like I love retweeting because people
send me some really fucking cool articles
and I'll retweet those.
And like a lot of it is like really
interesting shit and there's no way you're
going to accumulate all
that crap on your own.
You need some help out there.
And that's one of the cools things about
like having a successful podcast is
like your podcast now has a big following.
You could tell them,
hey,
watch Berg crushes podcast,
listen to Burke crushes podcasts a new,
and now everybody goes,
oh awesome.
And then they go,
wow,
I liked the way Tommy thinks.
You know,
Tom,
he makes me laugh.
Christina makes me laugh.
They're saying that
this is a great podcast.
I'll go check it out.
And then it branches off and they can
do that and the next person and Ari can
introduce a new one.
And absolutely.
That's the coolest thing about it is like
we know so many people that are really
fucking funny.
But in this day and age,
before podcasting,
it was really hard to
get your name out there,
but just as a standup.
But you had to have some TV in order
to be in the club.
Yeah.
And even then,
like it takes a long time for people to
take enough chances on you and then word
of mouth and returning to a
place over and over again,
like to build up markets.
It takes a long,
hard road.
But now all they have to do is be funny.
And you know,
podcasting too,
like this was kind of an
experiment for me was um,
I,
I spoke to you about it,
Elsa spoke to like Bill Burr,
Al Madrigal about putting out
an album on my own and you guys,
I'm saying separately all encouraged
me to do that and I did it on my own,
you know,
put it out.
But podcasting is the thing that
got really an audience for it.
You know,
like the,
like I,
I put it out there and
the whole like success of,
you know,
doing this thing on my own
where you feel kinda like,
like you're an entrepreneur.
Like,
like I'm just going to read,
I'm not going to go the,
the label route,
I'm just going to record it.
And I'm going to,
you know,
put it it,
just do it on my own and putting it
out there and then seeing if it works.
But seeing that the success is basically
because of the audience we built from
doing podcasts.
Yes.
It's a crazy connection to,
and don't you feel like kind of obligated
to be in communication with these
people?
I'm like,
absolutely.
And there's,
and keep making it more content.
Absolutely.
And it's so cool when
the standup now like,
Hey,
my audience isn't there yet.
They're coming now and it makes such a
difference when I look out and I can see
that they know who I am and I recognize
them and I see that we have this
wonderful connection and a talk to
the people after changed everything.
This is awesome.
Like this is what I've wanted for so long.
We brought Brian on stage in Austin
and they went fucking ape shit.
Oh yeah.
Brian got like a standing
ovation going on stage in Austin.
Oh yeah.
And did you ever watch that
interview Alex Jones did of us.
That was pretty cool.
Yeah,
it was good.
It was really cool.
Really good.
It was cool.
Yeah.
I came back and he might may or
may not have gotten the high,
oh,
I did a may or may not.
I did Brian's like a little desk
squad tour in Ohio couple months ago.
Right.
A month ago and I'm holy Shit,
when when you were brought on stage,
the place went fucking crazy.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's a completely different
world now because of podcasts.
You can,
you could literally make people
famous like in the real world.
Like they walk around like,
you know,
yeah.
It's interesting but it's like everything
that comedy networks never were,
comedy networks were never
really comedians networking.
This is like a real comedy network.
Exactly.
Cause all of us,
it's like,
you know,
if I tell you go listen to Joey Diaz a
CD and I'm crying laughing when I tell
you that you can trust me,
go listen to that shit.
You know what I mean?
It's like we,
we know what Ari's tastes or like,
you know,
we know a Dunkin station.
Yeah.
You get to know the rare,
rare time,
man,
this is never been a moment
like this for entertainers.
No.
We can just sort of do your
own connection with your,
with the audience that
wants to be with you.
You,
you're connected to them before that
would take a fucking pen and a pad and a
letter.
You know what I mean?
I mailed this time,
they get to know the real you,
which is an interesting
facet of celebrity.
Now I think,
and I don't know if it seems like in the
past celebrities had to have two lives,
like there's your public sphere and your
private and now those two spheres are
merging and they almost have
to because of this technology.
Like they have access to the real you.
Yeah.
It's kind of cool.
I mean the,
obviously there's
drawbacks to that as well.
If you're a douchebag,
if you're a Douche bag,
they're gonna know who you really are.
Yeah.
Correct.
Yeah,
yeah.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think that's ultimately
where the whole world was headed.
The,
the no secrets world.
I agree.
And no shame world.
Yeah.
Because everything this generation
is growing up in public,
not like we did.
We,
there's no notion anymore of like
keep that photograph in your locker.
Like now put the photograph on Facebook.
Everyone's going to see your titties.
Yeah.
Everybody's going to see it,
right?
Yeah,
I see them today.
Yeah.
It's um,
these kids today too.
If you stop and think about how
silly you were when you were 17.
Oh my gosh.
How many pictures of your
Dick would be online?
There would be,
so there would be chapters.
It would be like gigabytes of my day
would be everywhere.
College course famous for
being the dumbest kid.
Right.
Emails.
I would just upload it everywhere.
Yeah.
I would,
I would dick role everybody
instead of Rick Roll,
I would release the videos.
The video would start out with some music
and then I would jump out with my Dick
and funny ones too though.
Right?
With like sunglasses at my deck.
If I had access to that when
I was 17 anonymous access,
you'd all be seen my deck.
Is this a fact?
I'd get it out there.
So great.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Imagine these poor kids today.
Anything they do,
any,
some of them very Photoshop
makes a Photoshop of them
for hundreds of photoshops
and me and with a woman's body with a
dude banging me this whole bottom yet I
did half of them.
Oh red.
Remember the real dollars I made of you?
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Those Photoshop is amazing.
Like what you can do and not feel like
sometimes you have to look at a picture,
go shop.
Like someone's being like real subtle
fucking Mitt Romney's mom jeans photo.
So good.
That one is,
that's Photoshop.
Yeah,
but you look at it and you're like,
how's genes are really high on?
You're not sure I remember it.
And they raised him up just
enough to make it perfect.
This a political show,
uh,
for and for the web,
for comedy central,
I was a writer on it that Kyle
kinane hosted like earlier this year,
all leading up to the
election and the whole thing.
One of the episodes we were like,
God uses photo of Mitt Romney.
We had people like doing
research just to make sure,
like is this Photoshop?
This is one of those,
you're like,
this is so well done.
Like now that's,
that's not,
but
people were like,
like lawyers were like,
this is this really real is it?
Asking
for photos came out of his clothes and
he had experts examine them and show
proof that they had been doctored.
And then later he came out and said,
all right,
this is me.
I got doing coke and
dress up like a check.
He didn't want to come clean with that.
Yeah.
Well I liked that.
He probably got that monkey off his back.
They're probably fuck
with him for a long time.
Plus I'm sure like panties,
that Russian check,
if she's still alive,
she probably still tortures them.
That probably scared one day she's going
to do interviews and shit and he's not
gonna be able to pay her off anymore.
Let's see the ball kicking video.
Let's see that one.
Take it back home.
Oh yeah.
What the fuck man.
Too much.
Poor Oscar.
Yeah.
Do you think you'd like
to get ball kicked?
Probably.
Just like,
he's beaten so many dudes acids.
You want to beat his ass?
Fuck a woman.
You got tired of being like Super Macho
man and we just wanted to wear a dress
and shit.
Dudes that are into s and
M or being submissive or
lawyers and high power people
who will have to be in control in
their daily lives and then they,
they like a good ball kicking.
That make sense?
Yeah.
I control everything else.
I tell people what to do all the time.
Baby eyes at me call me daisy.
How can we save those people folks?
Is there anything we can do?
Do we just accept the part?
Is the fact that they're just
a part of the spectrum of life?
I think you have to
that are Alpha Britain,
one of the two.
All right,
well Alpha being an interim tech together,
maybe get
immediately starts hill sprints today.
Now there definitely.
It definitely is part of the spectrum.
That's the crazy thing
is knowing that like,
you know,
dude,
that's all that's all on there,
man.
Everybody what the fuck man?
Spectrum.
The spectrum of human beings,
you know and behavior.
It's mind boggling.
Yeah.
It was like the eight people.
I'm like,
that's what's that?
That's out there.
That guy that killed his gay
lover recently and chopped
up his ass on the camera
and was chunks of his ass on camera.
Battle ropes.
The guy in the bottom,
hassle Jujitsu,
many p he funneled into
position and get to the top.
Don't mount.
Take the knife away from him.
Okay,
now you're doing better known
but a shitty way to die.
God kills you.
Fucks you,
and then eat your ass on TV.
All icing it out.
Oh Christ.
What the fuck is with
people wanting the people?
What do you pray?
True.
Proven.
I would try it though.
I'd tasted you were dying.
Starvation.
Okay.
What race do you think
would be the most delicious?
Okay,
let's talk about this.
Let's see.
Okay,
cause I know in Sushi I like fatty
tuna the most because it's a nice fatty
piece.
So white people right
now we're pretty fatty.
Wow.
I'm going to go corn Fed Iowa woman in
the airport that looks like Sam Kinison
fat lady be,
that would be good.
But the,
the like the fattiness
would be more like a pork.
I think
it's like porn belly.
Yeah.
I don't think it'd be like tonight
at all to those fatty tuna.
Even when tunas are slightly fatty,
like the bottom area that's lean is fuck
compared to almost every other organism
on the planet and still pretty muscular.
Yeah.
You want to look at a Schumann?
Humans are gross.
I like pork rinds.
Yeah,
no more like a,
like a roast,
like a fat sloppy pork roast where the
meat's just fallen off cause it saw me
that a Cheetos me nutrition is as soda.
I kind of fat guy
with black beans or rice.
I like hot sauce.
I think you know the black guys are
pretty naturally muscular so I'd take one.
This is kind of fat,
so I get a nice mixture of like,
it's like a Ribeye,
marble,
the marble,
but not crazy.
Right?
Yeah.
And probably just the darker meat too.
It's probably more nutritious Indian
because it's already seasoned.
That's a good point.
That's a very good
price.
All that curry,
they say that like pineapple
flavors your loads.
Right?
I'm sure curry would flavor your rump.
Let's do it.
Curry Curry.
And your fats.
Well that's the case with bears.
You know,
with bears,
you want to eat a bear that,
uh,
gets shot after,
eats a lot of blueberries.
The bears that like if you eat bears it
apparently it's like some of the most
delicious meat you can have.
Really?
Yeah.
Because it literally changes the way
that their flesh tastes and they're fat.
They're fat,
has all this like blueberry in the fat.
It's crazy.
It's really nutty.
Yeah.
Let's do,
let's do a trip.
I'll go kill it.
Bear.
Let's go last night.
What's your race?
Probably Asians.
I just know just type is
either Brazilian or Asians.
Yeah,
probably.
Probably we would have like,
Asians aren't known for
being the most muscular call.
It'd be good.
Get a good cut.
Yeah.
Did you ever hear about that one guy from
pan who uh,
murdered a girl,
cooked her an aider and then got
off like on some insanity case.
So he's only,
he was only incarcerated for a small
amount of time with her for a long time,
like in a closet or something.
Uh,
yeah.
I don't know.
That's a good question.
Something along the lines.
I forget the guy's name,
but he was uh,
he was famous for it.
That's not true.
Um,
that guy,
I'll pull it up.
Japanese.
Well,
I mean give the guy a break man.
Like,
so he had a bat,
you know,
did a bad thing.
She probably did something wrong.
Right.
Probably said some shit.
She's talked a lot of shit.
This is his name.
Name East
side Sockeye wa.
Yeah.
It's pretty fucking crazy.
And apparently this dude like
has described like openly
in 1991 he murdered and
cannibalize a Dutch woman named Renee
heart to that part developed and after
it's released he became a minor celebrity
in Japan making a living through
public interest in his crime.
Wow.
He served time and a French jail.
Oh,
the French led them out.
Huh?
How long did he start?
Like,
listen,
he has suffered enough.
Yeah.
All he did,
he seem to want a medic and yeah,
he is under five feet tall and
he felt like he was weakened,
inadequate in the ADR because
he wanted to absorb her energy.
He fainted at the shock of shooting her,
but it woke with a realization that he
had to carry out his desire to eat her.
He did so beginning with
her buttocks and thighs.
After having sex with
her corpse interviews,
he'd noted his surprise that the corn
colored nature of human fat for two days.
So gawa eight various parts of her body.
He described to me as soft
and odorless like tuna.
Hmm.
Wow.
That shit's crazy.
You fucking nailed it.
That flavor on that role
cannot shape girl though.
This wasn't a
fatty,
I don't think he was eating
someone for their pork like,
yeah,
Sam Kinison like delicious.
He then attempted to do
dumped the mutilated
body in a remote lake,
but was seen in the act and later arrested
by the French police who found parts
of the deceased still in his refrigerator.
Oh my God.
Ago is wealthy.
Father provided a top lawyer for his
defense and after being held for two years
without trying on the French jail,
the uh,
blah,
blah blah.
I found him legally insane,
an unfit to stand trial and ordered
him to be held indefinitely,
an immense less tuition.
Good cow.
He spent over three months
there and then he went home.
Yeah.
How did they let them out?
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
The Japanese authorities found it legally
impossible to hold him because the
French government refuse
to release court documents,
which remained a secret to Japan claiming
that the case has already dropped in
France.
So as a result,
wow.
They extradited him to Japan
and when they let him in Japan,
Japan,
just let them go.
Oh Jeez.
It's funny how that always happens
between like when when somebody from a
country gets caught for
something in another country,
there's always like this irrational,
just we just want him once.
Don't punish him.
This is crazy.
This is
upon his arrival in Japan,
he was immediately taken to the Mat
Susanna hospital where examining
psychologists all found him to be sane,
stating that sexual perversion was
the sole motivation for the murder.
That sounds like a sadistic,
evil motherfucker then.
Right.
However,
the Japanese authorities found that
legally impossible to hold him because the
French government refuse
to release the documents.
So they said that this
guy was just a prevo.
He was totally sane to prayed and just
sexual perversion was the reason why I
killed this check.
He kills one and then he
makes a living as a minor.
Celebrities invited
like as a guest speaker,
um,
TV shows and shit.
He pretends to eat people's crazy box,
like biting people.
That's like if Ted Bundy
was doing talk shows,
like he wrote books about the murder.
He wrote books about it and
describing it in great detail.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
Man,
this is incredible.
Uh,
that judge Japanese,
Japanese are so different.
I know that culture is Joe.
Brian had all the places
that we've ever been to.
D It wasn't that the one that
most felt like we were on another,
oh yeah,
it was great.
I can't wait to go back.
But wasn't it like Taiwan?
It really felt highly,
it really felt like you
were in like another planet.
It's like you're in blade
runner or something really,
like be both it then.
It just got to hit again
with their earthquake.
7.2.
Yeah.
It's like an ugly.
So can I be for the Japanese?
That sucks.
I'm dying to visit.
I really want to take a trip one day.
Tough spot,
man.
You know,
being on an island that's,
that's got regular volcanic earthquake
tivity like that.
And after that big tsunami,
like the reality of that all setting in,
that's a tough spot to live.
It's not that big either.
You know,
how big is,
it?
Is a small,
smaller than Texas.
Right?
Small.
It must be unbelievable
amount of people to yeah.
Especially Tokyo.
Holy Shit.
And it's,
see it's such a modern city too.
It's really interesting,
right through their buildings.
And I love the writing,
like seeing the writing
all illuminated and shit.
It really does look like some alien ship.
It's fascinating culture.
Yeah.
Well they're not so good though.
You gotta get Outta here.
Powerful.
Brian Red Band is Outta here.
Ladies and gentleman,
he's got a boat and you
guys got to leave tomorrow.
I got to go.
Let's just wrap this bitch up.
Um,
if anybody wants a follow Christina
possessed ski all up in this bag,
you could follow her
at Christina with a c,
not one of those freaks that
spells it with a cabinet.
Ch Ch,
Christina Up pee on Twitter.
And of course Tom Segura is Tom Seg.
You are a Holla at you
boy I the cds in both of these.
Awesome.
Tommy's new CD is white
girls with cornrows.
Oh,
it is amazing.
Tell me you been killing it on the road.
I've been hearing,
I've been,
we've been talking about on the podcast,
I keep hearing it over and over again
that people tell me they went to your show
is I get messages on
Twitter like Holy Shit,
Tom killed it.
He's fucking awesome.
That's awesome.
You're getting your do man.
Thank you for all the Joe Rogan fans
that I get to meet that come to shows are
phenomenal.
Thank you for,
for supporting it.
Well,
I've been saying this for a while,
man.
You're one of the most unappreciated
standups in the country right now.
I really believe that.
Nice Guy,
man.
Thank you.
I really believe that you're
like one of the top guys.
All right.
Uh,
that's it for the podcasts.
You dirty fucks.
Thanks for having us.
Thanks for being on.
Thanks to ting.
Go to [inaudible] dot ting.com and
get 50 bucks off some groovy shit.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n
n I t used the code name Rogan.
Save yourself 10% of any and all
supplements and go fuck yourself.
But no,
it's good.
It's good to go.
Fuck yourself.
It's good.
Life is good.
It's good to fuck.
It's good to do everything.
Just do it.
Do it all with love.
You Dirty Fox.
And we will see you tomorrow,
tomorrow with mix master
Mike of the Beastie boys.
And you see Russell Peters and powerful
Russell Peters and then together.
Yes.
And then Wednesday the Great Don,
my rera will join us.
And Sunday Dennis Mckenna,
the brother of Terence Mckenna,
will a regale us with stories of
psychedelic adventures and uh,
we'll be promoting his new book.
So.
All right.
Uh,
thank you everybody for tuning in and
listening and thanks for all the positive
messages and all the love out there.
The amount of happy and positive people
that I run into online and in real life
as opposed to not happy
people is fucking staggering.
Okay?
It's the most incredible group of people
that we run into at these shows and
online.
It's amazing.
I don't know what the,
what we did to deserve it,
but thank you very much and know this.
We appreciate the shit out of it and
we're never gonna forget and we're never
gonna stop doing this.
All right?
So we'll see you soon.
Bye.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Shots got.